je vais essayer de réparer sa fab sont
riches en fruits
on va voir si on y arrive
c'est pas dit c'est pas dit qu'on y
arrive c'est assez étrange
sinon je vais la débrancher la
rebrancher
aurait peut-être
attend femmes c'est très très bizarre
et sallèles marche c'est ça qui marche
pas mal écrite allumé enfin dit qu'elle
marche annuelle points à michael marsh
ouais ouais ok
bon sinon bien on sera comme ça hein
c'est pas non plus gravissime qui
peuvent vraiment minces et de réparer
je vais essayer de réparer
ça peut tout faire sauter
d'affaires annoncée
ok bon ça a pas sauté pour l'instant
déjà on n'a pas tout fait sauter
ok bombe a eu quatre arrêts par ed
bref attendais pas du tout eu quatre
mois je m'attends à une tête à une
petrov en fait et surtout fermer l
histoire de faire une mouture boudreau a
battu fin 2 2 martial csssae drouot si
jamais tu tiens toi avec les noirs donc
je suis pas surpris fab ouais mais bon
des 4 tu peux faire un train des quatre
îles a rien trouvé sur des cas donc il
repart dans la paix travail joue le d4
maintenant
donc c'est quoi ces champions prend un
nom mais en france et pas forcément dans
ce qu'ils feront cap hancke et points 4
2 3 des 5 des trois des cinq essais des
proches sinon le couple aime bien faire
à ce moment-là sur faisait 3 et 5 des
princes elle est fondée sur des cinq le
vieux coup c'était cet iphone 5 un
kir transpose
pas tout à fait
prier prend dé 5,6
des prix des systèmes ça donc il ya une
différence est que les deux cavaliers
sont au centre d'études il en reste
c'est ce qu'ils jouent ouais bah c'est
l'ancien coo
bon d'habitude c'est quoi juste soudé si
ce n'est pas une partie de doute bof
des parties de plein de gens
car il est 17
plutôt rare
or ce rarissime pas rarissime mais je
sais pas j'ai plus ou des 600 têtes
alors moi juste n'importe quoi
et 17h10 c'est pas si fréquent -
afri-can donc et 17 ça va reprendre
du fou sûrement
parce que là ya pas trop envie de faire
un chantier des fois tu as des pressions
nous toi tu gagnes un pion un crible ans
donc et cette eurocoupe pardon c'est une
connerie qui prend 17 vous prend 17
hockey qui a validé deux et je quittais
de hockey vous
faire cavalier prend fou prend food et 6
ça a l'air d'être juste mégas
symétriques
ouais mais rock rock dommage cinq du
canadien
ok on va montrer ce qu en réalité
généralement quand on tient la symétrie
assez longtemps
ça va mais l'idée c'est damage 5 en
prison là d'un match 4 va pas
fait pour jouer asymétrique je me tourne
pas et attention de pas faire dame prend
1,7 non pas à cause de dame proche de ma
cause de dame reprend un sénateur du
gard de ti au nom de tous les jeux
symétrique il a pas loin donc des matchs
5 c'est le problème tu tapes en premier
j'ai six dames prendrait 5 et y'a pas
fou proche d'europe rage de dents prend
des cinq ce que la dame a pas droit de
sauter au dessus du fou c'est important
quand même que si les dames avaient
droit de s'auto dessus des fous ce
serait gagnant pour les noirs tout passe
par le double si cette fois non tu peux
pas enfin tu peux tenter le croit
d'agneau fin
tout jouer sur un croate dario ses
gammes en béton en affaires c'est peu
probable
donc qu'il prend des deux
papes france ur devant devant st t
mais je pense que tu peux ne plus
regarder santé femmes 1 ces morts et
obligé de regarder ya 2 0
derrière il ya plus de matchs donc dams
est peut-être sur dame de du coup on
échange mais ça serait vraiment turbo
d'euros
c'est sûr donc trop égale faute
d'arbitrage donc dames 7 ouais c'est
normal 2007
ou trois
je veux dire les parties imposture l'âme
b4e cette bonté tient juste faire de
fait feu on en parlera plus
fous et trois
questions pas de partie mesdames b4
c'est trop dame prend b2
la solution
de la partie ce serait magnifique
ce que dame nation c'est fou et trois
dames des cas d'amd 2 j'imagine dame
prend des deux rois prend des deux fous
des six rsa c'est à voir
mais je pense magnus peut vouloir faire
nul comme ça je pense que oui
personnellement
franchement c'est bien il fait comme il
veut il gère bien ses matches en général
ham et
sa méthode 1 je suis étonné mais est ce
que roy est face à un coût non je pense
que c'est les plans sont pas forcément
moins bien mais de toute façon c'est du
deux résultats ça aucun intérêt aucun
d'un emprunt de 7 si tu couvres être le
fournil dame b 4 mai mais les grands cas
sur deux il ya un grand roque aussi ça
va donc de trois dames bekaert est là il
peut être ces débats vrai peut-être
non mais ça ça ressemble plus à ce qu'il
veut faire il va pas je dois me devais
changer quand même des six après je ne
sais pas quelles sont leurs analyses là
dessus mais pourquoi pas
ça ça peut aller non
ça peut ça pourrait le faire et du coup
lui on peut l'enlever
non non elle face et moi à ta tout à
l'heure c'est ce que ça marchait plus
avait des problèmes et où j'étais obligé
d'isoler le problème pour voir ce qui
marchait pas et le faire remarcher
des problématiques exactement et
ouais mais je pense qu'il doit faire des
recettes toutes façons un autre coup
serait surprenant parce que la quinta
lydie food et si ce serait logique un de
base mais petit rouquin mais rock et on
peut pas faire petit rock donc ça c'est
chiant et assure ainsi arriver
ça c'est sûr que c'est un problème a
justement bien qu'alors quoi donc dame
soit je vois pas d'alternative ah
bon ça se trouve tu veux faire 2006
cet
hommage et tu vas grandcamp fait mais
moi tu te donnes pas ton fou
ouais après ils ont analysé en fait on
ne peut pas ouais mais un peu surpris de
dépôt
bizarrement il doit comprendre
que dams est celle coup dit bon il va
pas me faire des menus d'un volant pieds
d'un b4 machin et qu'est-ce qui me veut
ce que c'est dangereux il s'est levé sur
son temps non elle veut
dc6
bon baroque quasi sûr et je pense que
petit rock ça va pas donc qu'est-ce qui
fait il fait de 9,6 les préparant le bac
je sais pas je trouve qu'il est un peu
moins bien
c'est bizarre
mais pire est que peut-être dame m6 tour
eu un fou is his
way
damage 5 3 17 et u veut faire bouger
sinclair
attend méreau 17
xiam ouai mais rené surtout g5
des quatre
ok ok ça l'idée abba probable en temps
il ya une idée il a affiché un peu
n'importe quoi
il connaît en plus je pense alors fou
décisif sur soi que ce nombre d'intérêts
je vais vous dire je me
fous des six
dans les deux parties et petit rock
dommage qu'à taux de 9,6 il n'y a pas de
partie un très bon niveau
des six meilleurs joueurs noirs c'est de
1468 c'est extrêmement faible donc c'est
des partis et ces partis qu'on ne m'aime
pas en fait fatiha patrice et kébé des
deux camps qui est tellement rare
d'écouter doit avoir ses impressions
frei ne joue pas je sais pas je peux
est-ce qu'on a un ralenti je demande la
barre fab ah bah oui j'ai vu toucher un
truc sur l'échiquier su toucher une
pièce est obligé de la manger est ce que
touche une pièce super manche était pas
obligé de manger une autre pièce tu as
fait quoi c'est quand tu touches une
pièce adverse que tu peux manger était
obligé de la manger je pense à jean sûr
mais surtout je suis une pièce adverse
que tu peux pas manger est ce que tu vas
manger quoi qu'il en soit parce que
sinon ça voudrait dire qu'il serait
obligé de jouer tout proche c'est un
extraordinaire on va voir je pense pas
que ça mais bon on va mettre la marge
est en train de regarder la barre les
amis
je suis en train de regarder la var
va
va devoir faire un arrêt sur image
à l'autre chaux qui ne poseraient mais
si là dessus une pièce
pour trouver la bonne touche cette fois
oui mais elle est ce que
revoir fab les chevilles je suis obligé
un
nom il a touché que l'échiquier on veut
dépoussiérer enlever une poussière il
n'a pas touché de pièces ça passe les
amis ça passe il a le droit de jouer le
coup qu'il souhaite il allait requérir à
quoi me normal logique bon bah petit
rock ok bon l'illusion que de partir
dans la base comme on vous disait donc
la petit reynard c'est super con
mais je sais pas j'aime un peu mieux les
blancs
ok ce projet un temps d'avancé peut pas
être moins bien ses projets dans l'antre
tu disais quoi oui oui je veux dire
c'est que des fois une pulsion
symétrique c'est juste vraiment rien
lâche
c'est pas déplaisant quand les blancs tu
joues tu joues pour tu peux gagner ça
soit ils sont venus avec une scie sont
retournés sur la betterave sait qu'il va
jouer une position très safe avec une
petite chance
elles l'ont ils ont exactement ce pour
quoi elle était venue donc c'est une
balle de match un pour manu s'ils
gagnent aujourd'hui le match est terminé
c'est plié
j'en suis vraiment mais sa surface à
ceux ci s'est pas mathématiquement fait
mais ça s'est terminé
il ya quelques qui a demandé hier en
conférence de presse à l'epo quand est
ce que tu vas finalement attaqué dans le
match
sur quoi les pois répondu quand ce sera
l'heure d'attaquer c'est quand leurs
vaches lancé après le match
en six mois
mais c'est beau quand même on se serait
alors d'attaquer oui enfin c'était déjà
l'heure à la partie la partie 5 la
partie 7 je vais attaquer partie 18
14 rebonds pas de chance
on vit dans un chat à nancy marshall à
bien apprendre d'abord
c'était bouquin le truc de vlad bien
plus fraîches 6 avant un cui fracture
visite avec lui
en tout cas
j'aime bien la prépa de magnus
aujourd'hui ouais par rapport aux
circonstances aux matchs et tout ça
c'est pas ma il a pas rien en plus
donc c'est pas mal
franchement c'est bien
des gens des petites idées
est
vraiment pas mal
après on roy 17 août à montreux début
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas versez pas grand chose
ajoute forte et d'autre mais ces
six damage 5.17
moi je pense que les blancs c'est un peu
plus simple à jouer mais c'est quand
même pas mal pour un arc
chapelle du 3 résultat
c'est quand même pas mal pour que les
noirs ça y
est peut-être joue une sorte de
recomposer entre guillemets
mais je pense assez solides pour les
normes
est ce que
ce serait si mal pour un petit mieux
pour les blancs en fait
enfin si tu as des quatre attaques et
un truc
c'est bon tu peux te faire attaquer à
tout le monde est-ce que
ce que ne serait-ce que ces trois
dames bien sûr par l'autre côté du coup
de main apprendre à coude en france et
pas te l'envoie à chaque fois immobilisé
à tours a vite et puis je sais pas en
fait
un statut la pluie tomber quatre baies 5
choses comme ça mais c'est juste plus
vite désarmant l'ordi et
chardy est pas si folle est
terrible
bas salaires dont je pourrais la jouer
aussi vite food et si c'est pour
réfléchir à comment on va en fait une
nouvelle fois
comprendrai jamais dépôt dans ce match
c'est quand même fou des six rock parce
quand à food et sista rock a battu son
ex alors qu'ils ont en face à
crise à sainté 1,03
deuxième mi temps on peut zapper
ouais
encore évolué de 0 4x et ses terribles
femmes oued à mach 4 c'est vrai que ça a
un coût pour les noirs de machines autre
tribune il va falloir dire non il n'y
est pas du tout fou et six meilleures
aubaines en fait
c'est peut-être qatar on va déjà
c'est beau quand même si c'est déjà mal
je pense c'est pas vous je sais pas quel
point ça va pas
très étrange que je ne parle pas le coup
en soi mais il a joué food et 603 35
noms déjà il vas y vas tank et
c'est complètement débile ci fais ça
je sais pas si on est là
vachement beau jeu bon que
ça
s'arrête quand tu fais fou des six
[Musique]
barres ok tu sais que tu vas pas arguer
que faire de même si sous housse tu veux
tu fais d'un match 4 tu as envie de
faire un match 4 mais ça va pas trop de
matches 4 en fait y'a g3
dame prend des cas tous ces trophées g7
était encore le ressentent contrairement
aux blancs et tour est arrivé
et que c'était si tu commences par d'un
match 4 souhaite faire connaître faire
tout un échec mais je pense que j'ai
trop mais bon de voir un reportage est
trop aidé à me prendre il ya tous ces
trois donc en fait ça tu veux pas
alors tu vas te barrer
c'était pourtant kg 3
mais bon ce sera 17 c'est clair que
c'est une petite concession quand
en plus il ya pour l'instant ça marche
pas mais ces quatre c'est pas un marché
sur un 17 puis on prend d'un bébé 5
j'imagine ça me prendrait quatre sur ces
quatre donc ok mais tu as des thèmes qui
t'arrive dessus quoi
c'est fou
il appelle c'est dans la tête un
bon jeu mais
il n'a pas l'air au mieux
s'il a convenu de fichiers à bas la joie
parce que tu peut confondre
là c'est sûr que non
maintenant il est pas bien et donc il
fallait sûrement faire
alors pas fou de suisse dames 7 ou
d'investissement je sais pas
et 2007 food et rohff ou trois dames b4
ces trois dames propres investis j'ai
aucune idée de ce qui se passe là dessus
donc je sais pas si ma gni sur la fée
soir pour le coup
d'après la lettre en grand danger avec
les blancs comme avec les blancs comme
et blanc il peut pas étrange non pour ça
tu peux rentrer là-dedans joueurs que tu
auras toujours un père pète un truc une
merde
et s'il ya un danger quelques peurs
d'autres fait entrer dans notre
portefeuille à damas que c'est bon pour
décider de poche russe après trois
minutes
ça ne pas très envie quand même non
non mais tu peux réfléchir si tu sors tu
sors
pas typologie si tu fais alors tu as
deux heures à la pendule quoi
a pas envie
non mais on n'est pas en pointe enfin tu
vas chez un quart d'heure bon baptême
pas bah tu te dis bon ben je vais pas
prendre sa bombe à damas at j'élimine
food et 6 réfléchi avant de le faire
maintenant d'être sabah au final l'étude
conclut que ces dames et si ce que je
sais
en tout cas c'est très bizarre oui ou
non tu fais d'un rêve c'est sûr en tout
cas c'est très bizarre de faire [ __ ]
ici ce rock et se met à réfléchir ici
c'est peut-être la fin du match
aujourd'hui les amis non mais je pense
vraiment c'est vrai mal de matches ici
complètement
qu'est ce qu'une vie random ces listes
est il avait trois heures au lieu de
deux il aurait pas je me fous des civic
non mais ce que je n'aime pas sûr
ouais mais moi pour être bien sûr
j'aurais préféré mettre au vert oui
c'est reparti pour les analystes pmu
mais question qu'on raconte de plus sur
fait ça arrive pas à comprendre les gens
qui sont pas contents qu'on rediscute
haye femme fait honte à expliquer la
position et maintenant on va attendre
qu'une demi heure mais on
passe et
voilà je paye pas content je fais des
analyses pmu et on imagine un jeu match
de tennis on vas y tu te fais un service
et une demi-heure entre deux points
montmartin fou on va se montrer la
palette pendant une demi-heure du de
l'ice qu'ils remettent à l'instant
encore un assez bon
nous avons ce problématique qaïda menée
cette épreuve les droits des 7es
problématique s'ajoute qua non mais bon
surtout que s'il yad'autres stream
beaucoup plus intéressant et on a
d'autres
thèmes plus drastiques n'était pas
content
ce que tu veux qu'on dise de plus il a
acquis qu'il a quelqu'un dans
binaisse que le dépôt va faire rentrer
les problèmes de la position étonnante
les aboutissants sera peut-être pu faire
avant le truc c'est que magnus il a eu
son équipe dessus pendant trois quatre
jours depuis l'autre l'autre petrov donc
ils sont nés que cette petite idée
surtout maintenant qui mène au score que
les ans des analyses wen ont fait passer
20 heures sur la position a priori
minimum
pendant 10 secondes avec notre petite
turbine qu'on va tout montrer ce qu'ils
ont vu dans l'orne et 1
sûrement la ligne a cherché pour voir si
tu as un truc ou pas je sais que toi
mais surtout que là quand le mec tu es
fou des systèmes pos bout d'un moment
c'est pas une bonne gestion du temps je
comprends pas jouer le même convive en
fait
avec avec 0,5 oui ça aurait été mon
cours et fait que jamais reçue rock à
damas cinq à moi je vais réfléchir
mais ouais c'est pas terrible ce qui
nous a fait défaut
on va voir maintenant il est en capacité
de réfléchir et de et de résoudre les
problèmes peut-être ou pas
kalla s'est passé pas une erreur une
nouvelle fois sur l'échiquier c'est une
erreur mentale psychologique
bas
et la tête sous l'eau cette partie de 8
heures elle a fait mal quand même non
mais bon si à 48 heures quand même un
bon si tu peux pas trop mettre fin et y
en a tous les tons anodine en avançant
dans le championnat du monde mais ils
vendent à fait avant il a perdu des
partis qui aurait pu faire mal à la tête
mais généralement ils turbo 3 après bah
alors tant pis mais je veux dire c'est
un truc important à faire pour c'est
dans un match surtout mme carlsson a
priori va pas faire zéro défaite en 14
secondes
non mais
il fallait écouter nostra planus
français las il perd le match comme ça
il aura quand même la sensation d'avoir
perdu sans jouer honnêtement
ouais bah oury sa chance il perd
aujourd'hui qui perd comme ça tu auras
vraiment l'impression que
il n'a rien tenté quoi
c'est dommage un
bon là ça va forme trouver la défense je
sais bien sûr avec le roi 17 ça me
paraît pas foutu pour les noirs du tout
mais c'est mieux pour les blancs et
forgé précis côté noir d'aucun
pourquoi cette critique ses livres du
candidat prochain à nîmes on it
confirmant son plan de notre point de
vue la critique est facile ah bah oui
mais bon après on peut aussi mieux que
les micros et puis ne rien dire
voilà en fait du coup on parle le plus
aucun sujet ne plus rien on ne critique
furlan n'a plus d'avis sur rail enfin
ça vaut ce que ça vaut ont fait à notre
avis et on s'en fout en fait mais on l'a
dit avant on a dit avant ce qu'on pense
et ça se vérifie maintenant bon on est
content quand on est content ou pas les
on s'en fout c'est bien d'avoir une
cohérence peut pas juste dire un truc
lâm inverse et c'était
les corons d'auteur nevo tony exactement
et puis retour en bus on a repris quand
même la vie de vlad de basse et la vie
de l'adq on il a quand même été 18e
mondiale second temps d'un match de
championnat du monde les cochrane nique
il a dit avant le match que l'écho des
pages blaquart au kansas et vérifier je
sais pas assez
on n'est pas en accord avec l'avis d'un
haut naim ou quoi on est de l'accord
d'un mec qui
broeck est parti dans quoi fabriquer
personne qui a raison qui a tort comme
tout le monde mais
le mec est quand même
mais a très bien fait avant le match
c'était juste un avis bon qui s'est
avéré vrai mais en fait née peau quoi
qu'il en soit après une espagnole deux
espagnols avaient peut-être trop à un
moment tu peux
le sentir qu'en fait ça va
ça vient surprise en fait la partie
d'hier
il est donc aujourd'hui bal des faux
c'est pas d'âge et la betterave ça c'est
normal sont obligatoires pour le match
une bonne ouverture d'ailleurs quand on
est noir mais se couche ou dit si je
veux la vitesse de l'éclair pour que sur
roc d'un coup un merde peut-être que je
veux faire gaffe
donc c'est pas une gestion rationnelle
de son temps et de la position c'est pas
réfléchir au bon moment
voilà mais je sais pas pour autant qu'il
va perdre cette partie sais pas si c'est
pas si catastrophique mais sa part du
mauvais pied et c'est comme ça qu'il a
c'est pas pour ça qui perdra cette
partie mais c'est pour ça qu'il va
perdre le match en fait s'il fait ou non
mais même aujourd'hui david heyman enfin
c'est pas mon genre c'est comme ça qu'il
a perdu l'autre partie à deux jours
et
ça va pas quoi
dépassé par l'événement
après évidemment que la partie des deux
genres a laissé des traces
et serait chez tout le monde mais c'est
aussi la force d'un joueur doit rebondir
si je suis de par une fois pour faire
arrêter sa carrière bon
être qu'il y croit plus aussi un jeu pas
sur enfin je sais pas je sais pas je
sais pas comment il ya je le connais pas
un dépôt en fait
on sait pas comment il est
personnellement son état d'esprit etc
s'il n'y a que 1 point d'écart c'est pas
non plus évidemment il est mal quoi déjà
avant le match et 47 des favoris est
clairement et le jour human à 0 bon
voilà c'est d'imiter chance mais non
mais je pense que le fait vraiment pour
moi sa connerie c'est vraiment ces
ouvertures avec les blancs
c'est déprimant en fait tu vas à chaque
partie sud et print une espagnole je
sais que vous mille fois mieux qu'on
veut toits qu'il va à bath tu le sais
toujours pas espagnol dans ce lille là
soit pas compris soit soit sur les
centres je sais pas
si t'es sur
qui fait pas il fallait le comprendre en
fait il s'est vraiment enferré dans un
truc h5 qui est bon il remporte d'un
match 5 du coût mais
en fait j'ai ainsi fait all in avec les
normes
alors bon c'est un coup y'a plus de
damages 5 et ils vont jouer gros crac
opposé
on va voir
mais ça m'a l'air hyper dangereux voire
peut-être tourner à faire bref 8 mai sur
témoin bien tabac a été reconnecté
je sais pas mais tu vois ça revient à ce
qu'on a dit d'ailleurs ce qu'on disait
hier c'est que les seules positions
qu'il a eue pour jouer c'est avec les
noirs 1 alors après il est un peu moins
bien de base mais au moins il joue son
jeu et c'est ça va encore dans le sens
où mais là c'est un peu un cadeau h5 je
pense que c'est une bonne idée
j'utilise pourquoi ou tu t'en fous est
ce que tu veux vraiment savoir
dit comme ça peut-être pas choisi en
fait quitte à faire de la merde à temps
et à la faune est au moins au moins
tenté pour tenter quelque chose quoi là
tu as l'impression h simcoe tu cliques
quoi - c'est un clic
quitte à faire de la merde au moins au
moins cliquer quoi bon allez on va voir
j'aime bien le coup enfin je meurs je
sais pas ce
qu'ils se lâchent qui joue ses coûts
ouais ce qu'il aurait dû faire sur ces
quatre parties avec les blancs ils
commencent à le faire aujourd'hui c'est
trop tard c'est pas dans la bonne
position mais au moins on va avoir un
peu magnus fasse suer j'ai peur que ce
soit trop tard dans ma qu'il aurait
fallu le faire à égalité un truc pareil
là ils mènent d'un point même si père
c'est pas grave oui mais bon tant qu'un
parent a vite perdre en laisser sur
cinq
ce
qui peut infertilité c'est con mais que
très peu en valeur le niveau des joueurs
dit qu'en fait le problème c'est qu'on
met jamais en
exergue le niveau des joueurs mais enfin
c'est déjà c'est pas vrai en plus de
cela sur ce machin il trouve que ça joue
pas très bien
mais ça on n'y peut rien c'est pas de
notre faute par rapport à ce qu'ils
peuvent faire ça joue relativement
moyennement grands matches championnat
du monde savait pour les jours des fois
c'était des parties très propre il n'y a
rien à dire en fait est
bon prêt partie de nos jours avec
comparer un caruana carlos nc - internet
mais bon après je sais pas quoi dire
niveau des joueurs ils sont
intrinsèquement très fort quoi
higuain scène bachem à face à soissons
et l'autre sont et john l'epo annoncé en
dessous du dernier match où on est mais
des fois il faut toujours rien que ce
que tu peux intrinsèquement faire un
petit côté dommage c'est comme ça
on stresse et ouais il ya le stress et
la période coffee tea les a fait un peu
régressé mal-être et puis pour moi je
vais je dois je le redis moi c'est un
peu le mans leiria rien nouveau champion
du monde y remet rien en cause aux
échecs face à il changerait en fait y'a
pas de concept
ya pas de nouveau concept tient rien de
pas de nouvelles ouvertures pas notre
truc mais cinq ans qui écoute on va
avoir fait le truc qui m'inquiète c'est
soro centre 7 de lamy kaki pu voir ces
quatre quoi mais il va cliquer h5 vata
aussi c'est peut-être qu'il veut nous
faire un petit damache 4g 3 sur ces 4
bien mais tu te barres
et après tâche 4
donc ok on verra
tu peux cliquer pourquoi pas afin si je
suis assez surpris de ce début de partie
on ne fait pas ça chez vous 5 avec un
rose sang de se prendre une tour en vain
s'est lui dit gasquet a
donc lancé un rappel une partie de
ludwig en ont bloqué un séisme
[Musique]
ok fait curieux on va voir ce parti
a pas une partie j'avais laissé son
adversaire au qui est quand même après
pour être bien sûr
c'est terrible
bon ça ressemble un truc bien joué mais
là pour le coup
intéressant
c'est un cas un gars qui encore le
stream du sun t'attends pas du respect
pour les joueurs non mais si témoins
juste des gens qui ont autant a analysé
deux parties à regarder ton de haut
niveau que nous
cette fable c'est quoi la question il
dit qu'on respecte jamais les joueurs
ici mais jussie témoin des gens qui ont
analysé autant de parties de joueurs de
haut niveau que nous
sur une chaîne perso et à chaque fois
les analyses sont propres et pro 1 sais
pas c'est pas dur ici de coûts
enfin juste ça n'existe pas en fait
pas bon c'est terrible une portée de
lecture historique
dit répertoire des choses quoi non plus
les parties des grands tournants on m'a
fait une quantité de parties
de noir de 100 tonnes
je crois que rien que des parties de mv
l âge et même pas tous comptabilisés
avait juste sur celle que j'ai
comptabilisé fassions et déjà 125 parti
rien vu elle mais je pensais plutôt 180
ou plus même
surtout que cette somme est fine et
c'est vrai que top 2 mondial et des
villes mais enfin je sais pas si m pap
et l'autre jour quand je regarde le
match c'était synthé psg ouais mba pays
rata un contre un avec le gardien ouais
on doit dire quoi qu'il a fait une super
frappe et c'est un super duel ou que
bombay il a raté le goal était trop fort
c'est marrant fait dire j'ai vu un petit
extrait sur eurosport de course
poursuite de vélo et contador sont très
énervés le français s'est pas mis debout
il dit mais tout le monde le fait il ya
que les français qui font pas il ya pas
leur entraîneur cayla d'équidés pas un
bon match et ben ils tissent des fois
quand il ya truc qui va pas les échecs
dans l'action qui peut rien dire quoi
quand il ya des partis qui vont dès
qu'ils sont géniaux ou quoi mais quand
ça va pas te sens tu peux pas dire que
ça va pas c'est pas possible en fait
franc dans le mur ce que nous ferons
dans le mur pas très bien tiré et corner
direct dans les bras du gardien bombe
pas grave c'est que y'a des fois il dit
bien centré son corner quoi donc il
reste qu'on a remis à tirer
aussi je mette en émaux tonne me pour la
journée
[Rires]
quant à son salaire de l'appui moi je
croyais mode lent pendant 120 minutes
allez hop
on est tranquille et c'est lors de la
pub en plus croissant quatrième but
rennais magnifique
on est tranquille mon fab
au moins on est tranquille ça fait
plaisir et puis la petite pub qui par
voie parfait voilà une journée qui
commence bien avec une petite pub as un
petit h sinko qui par un petit caillou
il est maniaco but un petit cazères une
lucarne lucarne
lucarne aide et puis il faut que l'on
enlève aussi les points chaîne parce que
les peuvent parler avec les poings
chaîne encore
peut-être que celui parlé de prochaine
ça va quoi au nom
temps je suis en train d'essayer de chez
plus où ça
bouge plus et j'ai la flemme de chercher
pour demain je ferai ça pour demain
fabien qui attireront plus parler à quel
point celle non plus
au moins on sera bien tranquille
magnus qui réfléchissent le h5 c'est
vrai étonnant mais pourquoi pas en fait
jamais bien joué en fait à vrai dire je
sais ici c'était étonnant et puis s'est
ressaisie quoi ils jouent une partie il
tente un truc quoi je sais pas c'est
mère-courage 5 mai fois un truc un peu
bizarre mais magnus bon pour le coup
c'est bien réfléchi
un c4 ça paraît logique après c'est ce
qui est logique ainsi on ouvre le jeu
quand l'adversaire est mal moins bien
développée en tout cas donc avoir 6 4
quoi d'autre tour à tour
un salaire d'être un coup aussi que
marans
et c'est peut-être pas si grave
peut-être ça va peut-être ça vas voir je
vais un peu creusé avec l'ordi
vas-y un creuset d'où une pelle
wow ça va on va faire monter un peu en
profondeur
voir à quel point c'est grave ou pas
sa perte à pain
t'as combien là pour le moment en
profondeur ouais ouais juste 27 il dit
quoi je 0,54 ce cadre
il faudra voir si ça une tendance à
augmenter ou à jardy impossible
sur le cloud
bon on dirait qu'en gros se confondent à
faire d'un f3 c'est pas la fin du monde
mais quand même moi je ferais bien un
test de ces 400 millions qui n'a cessé
en fait
il ya cessé tout à fait
c'est cède
alors cessé qu'est ce qui nous dit c'est
celle
ci s'il aime bien ces quatre mais il
fait que 0,34 il faut que ce soit 0,34
mais déjà le coup sûr ces quatre faut le
jouer quoi 2006
jada 6 c'est pas si simple sur ces
quatre d'y penser
cette envie de faire des français et en
latin shebab ont attaqué et ça ouvre le
jeu et donc c'est 4 de 9 6 l'idée c'est
de donner la case f4 aux fous
et
c'est dur à gérer pour déposer raison je
pense vraiment dur à ce problème
au revoir mais c'est peut-être un peu
plus sa position
web on lui dit capable un peu mais bon
magnus le truc c'est quand même
relativement
ses seins pour les blancs c'est pas non
plus la guerre totale sur l'échiquier
j'ai l'impression que même dame c'est un
symbole
pourquoi
même roue à chien reste avantage blanc
c'est extraordinaire en fait tous les
coups sont venus voudrait en fait c'est
les coupes sont mauvais pour les
violences des fiches 4
x 4 sapeurs terrible non plus et f4
l'option c'est moche mais quatre mauvais
aussi
bref 5 et 6 h salle jean g4
du coup tu donnes un truc comme un brh
siat calaveras symbole mgk n'a pas être
trop bon non plus
j'aime bien on fait du mauvais
sebuku f5 fuji si cela est juste et f4
qui dit quoi passer ça vous qu'on fera
pas mais
à quel point qui vivrait philippe
rochard aussi c'est un peu ma chérie
quatre ans on se rend mauvais l'fou d2
on se fait un gros trou quatre gardes
fous je vous conseille pas de jouer que
ce soit ici ou tout le temps mais bon
c'était juste pour savoir ce qu'en
disait alors dit
elle c'est ces cartes af 6 6
3 c'est ça qui fait froid
superlatifs aa
alors 2 rue des
postes
fessé 5 ouais ça fait quatre ans
qu'on
se bat pour la mariée tu peux plus jouer
petit rock battage 5 en l'air on peut
tout à faire j'ai six
amis de l'estran
et bien que les cinq des clodos
g5 ouais voilà
grand
labeur
ah ouais ça peut turbo perd 20 pour les
peaux
ça peut turbo perdre fab bah ça sera la
fin du match
écoutons et john tembo minutes c'est sur
ce qu'il convient de faire c'est sûr
c'est ce qui va faire un prêt a fléchi
après ça dépend est-ce qu'il veut qu'ils
aient vraiment aucun risque qu'elles
sont actives âgées autrement et ça sera
une chance après 6,4 ce pays qui gagne
mais ça a vraiment l'air chiant à jouer
pour les noirs
et le dos même si ce machin c'est le
meilleur cas de figure c'est ce qu'on a
vu sa journée de fer
et donnant le début de partie tuer il a
finalement lâché ses coups en tilt avec
les noix après ses parents au poker des
fois tu tilt et finalement celle axa
gagne enfin a tout foutu poussette et de
ouais
mais bon là va faire en voulut
incroyable pour revenir volumes là il
faut du beau lula
après la chance le beau lui sourit aux
audacieux exactement
mais ça peut vraiment être in turbo
défaite qui conderanne aurait
complètement jan ah bah oui normal à
n'importe qui de nouvelle défaite c'est
fini
bon alors un petit tweet en disant que
réussit la première balle de match en
magnus
on va voir
on va voir s'il a converti ses deux
balles de match
à 6 parties derrière
tracy partir on a mis match en fait on
vient d'entamer la
moitié du match
magnifique
c'est magnifique
bon ben je peux passer un bon temps ici
à te sont à considérer ces options son
tour à son c4
bon je sais pas trop quoi d'autre
regarder en fait
ouais d'un f3 mais bon
c'est 4 ce qui donne de loin on peut
avoir envie juste en disant bon après je
fais flou et quatre vingts déjà getac
des cinq après celle qu'a d'échangés
soutien aux noirs donc jouer avec un fou
un peu mieux que l'autre j'ai ité
histoire d'âme h4 machin sur
h2o je sais pas c'est parce que je
ferais mais je veux comprendre à faire
un truc là dessus quelques attaques
mais bien joué un set cette prépa
franchement ça a l'air de rien projet
que sert à rien après analyse mais quand
tu es confronté au truc et que tu
comprends pas le danger qu'il ya
derrière créé un petit poison
tu peux vite je fous des 6 es tu te
diras même l'inde en fait et donc c'est
typiquement ce qui s'est passé en fait
et donc
donc
croisade
s'est fait boissonnade
si
il est facile il n'allait pas venir
franchir toutes les pièces même temps
non maintenant à voir comment
nous
le match sera joué pendant la
préparation finalement
sa fille comme ça dans les choix scanner
vos je peux pas me parler de dire que
c'est mal préparés en
terme d'intensité de temps de travail
physique je suis sûr qu'il a très bien
travaillé mais finalement je suis
travaille pas sur le bon sujet du temps
perdu quoi
ouais surtout dans le jeu il n'a pas
paru en dessous un
ouais bon voilà enfin parle donc
on va voir pas ressenti comme mené d'un
point en même temps sur six paires
aujourd'hui c'est un concept un peu long
le score mais pas immérité
en gros le truc c'est que quand tu as
une opportunité faut la saisir c'est le
réalisme c'est le cas dans pas mal de
sport mais là c'est surtout allez on à
paris 6-2 avec les noirs ils avaient
vraiment ouais il a essayé en fait
qu'est ce qui n'a probablement pas
compris qu'ils pouvaient faire il était
juste trop inquiet
ils voulaient pas perdre quoi et c'est
là que je dis dans la préparation dans
la proche aussi dans la proche qui n'a
pas été vraiment une approche de serrure
est quoi
en mode en fait le truc bizarre c'est
que oui i lost approche meknes peau au
moment où il a voulu s'en libérer c'est
pas son style
il ya
encore deux parties ah oui c'est ça ça
peut être une approche d'avant
décidé en amont quoi et
que peut-être chez pas et des
dissonances il entendait les mecs bien
oui surtout tu prends pas de risques que
lui quand même y voit sa position
exhiberont je sais pas en fait
ça frétille et quoi
donc il essayait de s'en libérer bon
aujourd'hui là ils envoient complètement
zappé un objectif entre autres au bon
après il fois ça marche en pratique quoi
est-il telle adversaire ou quoi mais bon
magnus si populaire purement inquiet sur
les images n'ont
pas l'air très tranquille
il est fort ce magnus
il va falloir en firent ou déjà à flavin
pour en venir à bout de ce jour faire un
fil rouge est en forme pour venir à bout
de magnus on va dire fabi était pas si
loin mais là maintenant je sais pas s'il
sera encore capable de refaire le même
match
déjà six provinces encore un peu
pourquoi pas
ça peut un
peu
farruggia requinquer
qu'invaincus ça tellement d'options
seule chose qui peut lui arriver de mal
dans cette partie à manu c'est de
vouloir trop assuré en disant de toute
façon les espagnols au noir je les tiens
facile bah je crois pas qu'il va partir
c'est à dire sans médaille les occasions
de tuer le match un peu oui là ils me
disaient on y va essayer quand même
après je suis sûr que si les peaux des
fonds très très bien
la tenir
mais
[Musique]
si last occasion il va pas laisser filer
non
et il aura bien raison de ne pas la
laisser filer
ben faut pas y aller quoi
ce très beau clip oh
après demain
écrit rui lopez pour qu'il revienne
j'ai écrit crier bruit lopez pour qu'il
revienne
il est très heureux qu écrire une
audience il crée le buzz il ya pas de
zéro oui mais c'est pour ça il recrue
lopez dans un lieu où ils vont
finalement à part tenter quelque chose
et si cris des petites antilles marche à
la 4è
je paie
seront bien sûr
du chanteur back of
alors tout un tout un album de the back
of bayti
emily batty il baptisa km avec l'âge
j'ai aussi mis les bacs et en fait
annuler
mais pourquoi kiss à qui ça ça freine le
bouquet
c'est vous que j'aime bien cette et
motally 120 milles 8 et ce bonne nuit
c'est quoi ça pendant deux heures dans
la que les votes en fait c'est à 320
second terroirs parler une fois toutes
les deux minutes droit de faire que des
émeutes est faux et recel ok
ça fait souffler quoi
d'aller de vigo si le groupe baca gimme
gimme gimme d'euros
[Musique]
je crois qu'ils vont ressortir dix
albums l'aléa bah
[Musique]
oui j'écoute ça donne 40 ans plus tard
la grande musique les années disco
bas qui sont 1,8 à taratata
florent bador florent
va nous présenter ton nouvel album
est bien un clip apparemment devoir
cliquer
j'ai entendu appeler dessous je dirai
pas plus mais
complexe les règles y réfléchir il ay la
pléthore d'options difficile de ce qu'on
paie
quoi qui joue le sera mais en fait après
ce coup là
ces quatre salles art allemand coup
quand même bon c'est pas mal c'est que
petit à petit on se rapproche de la
pause quand même
au hockey oui
c'est vous qu'on peut laisser les gens
parler pendant la pause
toute façon vers le sol de retour ouais
à être tout en bloc
jeudi fabre en pro d2 sous les at il une
ans
j'imaginais quoi puis si ça finit pas
trop tard on peut aller manger à ma faim
ah oui
une bonne idée ça le mafé peut partir à
tout moment
on va être tellement heureux si on a de
ma fait
je pense que prendre le marché aux
poulets mois gakwaya m'a fait pou les
lie à agneaux aussi mes poules à
[Musique]
panionios et peut-être bohain un peu
tous les coups
en cette enceinte et s'améliore pas je
suis toujours 04
ça fait défoncer dans tous les sens il
vient de faire quelques heures à
domicile c'est pas la crise quand on se
souvient des cris de ce nom peu la honte
en fait de prendre quatre à domicile
après bongo ça peut être plus haut à 335
6 1 vu la gueule du match mais c'est pas
vrai mais c'est vraiment lui miliana on
est d'accord tu es très moche mais bon
ça nous arrive des fois depuis quelques
années qu'on est très nul un petit 5 0
contre lyon 4 0 contre monaco 5 1 500
comptes par
ifaw ou annonce du web on tue mais ce
que tu as fait débat professionnels bah
je crois pas je crois que fois très très
grand match la satire de
missionnaires ne veut pas en avant quand
même le niveau 2 au niveau de la défense
le marquage la ligne de hors jeu les
buts c'était on a vraiment bien joué
leur jeu pas de chance il y avait hors
jeu mais bon j'ai un cinquième très bien
joué mais grange huawei
donc
magnifique
il ya un triplé dans le match oui
terrienne forme à strasbourg passé par
l'om et rennes depuis un moment
mais pas ce que je vois
ce très beau quand même que menez peau
il gagne aujourd'hui avec air voit une
partie
de fouine quoi ah bon en fait je serais
content
très content aussi
ian sa relance le match l'intérêt du
match là c'est sûr qu'il ya de 0,10
dallas pas grand intérêt à quoi ces
magnifiques et sheth com/fr kuczynski 23
pub d'affilée sur thiès comme
international 23 pub de 30 secondes
d'affilée et une minute trente de pub
extraordinaire
au bois là ils se font plaisir en orange
suisse fait plaise
quand il faut payer les soldes c'est
plus compliqué mais quand il s'agit dans
23 pub d'affilée on est tellement
heureux record en cours où ça continue
ou quoi c'est en pause depuis 20 minutes
plus haut mais c'est extraordinaire
oh c'est magnifique j'ai quasiment envie
d'aller voir leur live fois que 20
minutes de pub consécutive du grand live
en général elle a pu un peu avec ça vaut
quoi ça fait plaise
ah non mais tant dans la musique ça va
être la musique on vas tu te montres
magnus et de mettre des pubs à sa
croissance est extraordinaire il ya
trente cinq mille personnes qui
regardent ouais bah c'est beau c'est ce
que je disais sur tweets chabot coups
d'algorithmes en fait le truc commence à
être regarder tu peux mettre un écran
noir alors va te fumer de la petite
musique un plus ça jusqu'à l'est où il
faisait la pub à fond mais c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'on va passer la musique
la musique voilà m
pendant pendant la pause la musique n'a
temps d'aller courir on va calquer
renshaw
un petit preview
un peu de violon même pas vraiment fait
on sait pas
c'est terrible
à germer des émeutes quoi
je leur mets des vlad et je le remets
démarre louge l'armée a non je remets un
mur de k crew mais oui le mur de cas
crocs c'est un coup de crosse à je vais
écrire encore un coup de cas cros
et on leur met un mur de k crew quoi
et je mets des cas cros
magnifique je suis bon en
a aujourd'hui ayrault qui a ruiné quatre
aux fortes voire
c'est magnifique ils ont les cas croquis
sont là quoi
à magnifique le petit mur de cas crocs
il est beau ce mur a aussi un beau mur
en bas kibaki fo ap ce cas par accident
le chat sauvage un des beaux murs comme
ça ne serait pas bien
il est beau le mur
à tintin c'est moi en fait c'est une
belle journée un truc aujourd'hui qui se
passe
à un mur de cacao qui part comme ça ils
sont dégoûtés les américains on va se
faire ban c'est n'importe quoi les états
clés k crew eyes n'aime pas trop les
murs quoi ils sont pas très mûr passe
quand ils sont beaucoup de gens et
que les français soient recteur k'kruhk
ouais mais c'est normal c'est un coup de
croc enfin pendant une demi-heure son
casse marche pas en plein championnat du
monde c'est un coup de cas chrono à bord
âgés ont alors scandé publ oui si pu
magnifique gros aux eaux assez
intéressant des pubs ciblées atteint 5%
[Musique]
c'est bon on est tellement heureux de la
pub enfin je crois comme vous plaignez
de la pub c'est hyper intéressant c'est
une sorte que sa maman fait un
bateau qui coule ou je sais pas un peu
une forte night un chapitre iii un
raz-de-marée rien quand on a ressenti
comme très mal tiré par don très bien
tiré mais un abonnement carte cadeau
mais très bien défendu à offrir des
cartes cadeaux sur twitch à sa
magnifique 15 cent de réduction sur les
carcasses en ce moment au prince un
super cadeau d'anniversaire sa de noël
oui bon d'anniversaire aussi d'ailleurs
vous trouver sa voie armées armée de mer
ce format il veut savoir
[Musique]
le bail qui ce temps tu appelles en fait
d'un bug distante appel pour défendre
nos patries la marine pakistanaise
recrute
youtube sur youtube sur twitter la pub
du type sur twitch magnifique
ghana camurat sur la pub vers les débits
stream tout ça c'est ça en fait
d'obtenir le tout le monde a pu bloquer
magnifique
et uys et qui
je sais pianiste fait de la musique non
ouais il fait de la musique naissance
une musique alors
parfois on and on préfère faire le
scorpio et la bosch x gardena enfin quoi
vous êtes heureuse non pour souffler sur
des feuilles sur les faits
le michoacan centre très heureuse de ce
nom est trop sérieuse as-tu fait un peu
tout en fait ça c'est une trousse à
outils ahmed extérieur souffre le
synchro sonneuse ils sont revenus c'est
ça remarche s'est parfaitement remis de
la pub pour être bien sûr que les gens
qui attendent et sera encore stimule
c'était marrant mais
dommage pour vraiment posé un
bon il se passe rien les gains pour le
moment on attend le c4 1 on est à 35 de
réflexion quand même déjà femmes c'est
pas mal de temps dans cette note dont
trois heures
ouais c'est sympa
bon peut être un petit coup de musique
pour cette petite pause il par la nuit
at il a passé totalement
à l'écart au nom
bon
suite
problème je me suis trompé une micro
en fait comme on a changé les micros je
m'étais trouvé de micro vous deviez pas
très bien m'entendre un an c'est pas un
problème
c'est pas un problème parce que
ça tape ça
tape tout de suite
fit france et 4 es le roi noir est trop
faible ensemble déjà parlé tout à
l'heure avec fab
donc ça ça va pas à
à
ces quatre c'est vraiment fort après ce
qu'ils regardent damache quatre menaces
match j'ai trois dames tran
c3 et dames g4 c'est peut-être ça l'idée
en fait ce pas l'idée de l'ordi ça c'est
l'idée qu'on avait tout à l'heure
ça
dangereux pour les noirs mais
peut-être d'apprentis on prend dix on
vous prend g7
dont j'ai huit tours un roi des 8
est encore floue f6 là
maintenant ça a l'air qatar
salaires catastrophique ça vraiment la
cata ce prix partout et
ça a l'air complètement catastrophique
les micros quatre ans fait aujourd'hui
sans compter bien
un wes catastrophique
je suis associé ni chaos qui dit que y'a
doit se sentir en meilleure position
parce que carsen et beaucoup de temps à
réfléchir pourquoi ah oui on va y aller
c'est sûr qu'il ose dire alou je suis
vraiment beaucoup mieux avec les noirs
ça fait toujours plaisir de voir son
adversaire afficheurs beaucoup osé à
bonbons - il est surpris où il n'est pas
à l'aise ou comme ça il doit être
content mais quoi parce qu'il est mieux
à ce point
bah oui quand on a certes plombe soit
une position jeu sur une demi heure ou
quoi
tant mieux car et il y avait un conseil
de john mann un grand joueur qui écrit
des livres sympa
qui disait que vaut mieux pas réfléchir
plus d'un quart d'heure par coup sûr un
coût
ce qui a priori tu vas pas fait un truc
de génie
manu je le disais aussi
d'ailleurs quand tu commences affiche
plus de 40 minutes magnus
c'était vraiment la cata
il y arrive
mais bon là le truc c'est que ces
quattro va partir
j'imagine dans tous les cas fait il peut
pas se tromper et se paye possibilit une
touche aussi pas un cas de figure où ça
peut coûter parce que si avec un ou deux
bons choix on pourrait dire il va il va
faire un truc qui va pas
mais
mais là le truc c'est qu'il peut pas se
tromper
pourquoi plutôt à vichy plus tu fais un
coup de main basse est juste et pas très
confiants sont là et on fait des sites
avait trouvé ce qui te plaisent et
aurait joué plus vite quoi c'est un truc
si tu commence à réfléchir beaucoup au
bout d'un moment tu commences à perdre
en lucidité t'as vu trop de variantes
trop de positions et se tenait en même
temps donc ça va pas quoi
mais là il devrait jouer un magnus
moan et ça pue trop trop trop hard et
ouais
mais tu vois c'est marrant parce que des
piani la fin un coup dans son style
la pousse à la réflexion ben il a mille
à l'ap le truc c'est que la position et
pas assez bonne mais c'est vrai qu'on
sent que s'il joue son jeu et qui se
libère sur les dernières parties peuvent
vraiment retourné le match quoi mais ça
passe par une un changement d'attitudes
en ouverture de tout pas déjà par une
nulle aujourd'hui oui vont pas perdre
aujourd'hui puis puis après un
changement d'attitude dans le match mais
tu sens que quand il compte il lâche ses
coups et qui joue à la yann ben c'est
pas si clair en fait
on va voir on se retrouve en guise de
temps chez nénette coup de souffle
non mais c'est marrant quand même à quel
point c'est psychologique c'est match
à ses traits psychologiques
un combat très différent des tournois
habituels
cinq en tout cas ça a eu le mérite de
déstabiliser magnus
5 d'une position tu t'attends à petit
avantage ou un bon avantage sans risque
bon tu sens qu'il veut tomber tes te
faire du h4 h3 du damage 4 provoqué g37
ferrache 4 cartons voir et te dire bon
at what are ok c'est censé être bien
mais mais bon moi je veux garder mon roi
là je vais entourage suite je vais
l'ouvrir sur la colonne h essayer de
t'agresser alors bon français sont très
ambitieux de la part des noirs et
je reste convaincu que c'est bien pour
les blancs visuellement ce que je
pensais de base le redis confirme vous
l'affirmer mais
bon faisons pas le redis il faut pas se
tromper
fait qu'il doit vouloir vraiment rester
en contrôle magnus ceux ci ce sera
peut-être à face il faut pas avoir envie
de trop être en contrôle tout le temps
d'en bas du jour
mais
mesdames f3 pour faire fuir c'est
peut-être le truc pour mieux contrôler
en fait
on vraiment lever toute chance
d'attaquer et une dispute pas le plus
fort mais je sais de presser un peu et
puis sinon ultrasons c'est pas grave nul
en approche
c'est pas grave viser là nul ça ne te
fait pas peur pas du tout
avoir un face on a plus grand chose à
dire
ben ça fait trop longtemps que ça joue
pas ça fait à peu près une heure cinq
qu'on est quasiment sûre cette position
à 5 machin vous demandera vraiment fait
le tour
amy veut rejouer avec 20 secondes à la
pointe du rsa lui avait bien réussi
enfin que j'ai gagné grâce à ce qu'il
aurait pas yann aurait pas autant
pousser il aurait pas gagner sinon ça
qui a poussé ian à la faute au final
marin
demain
un explique-t-il ça a l'air d'être bien
plus tôt
c'est pour bien les ces dames 7 pour
bien faire drôle c'est pourquoi ses
traits pleutres c'est le coup le plus
plu l'autre la position un petit mur de
peloton peut-être c'est pourquoi moi
sera vite oubliée 4 mais il s'est passé
pas de chaise comme qui trollent c'est
pas d'âme eu deux ans avant demain
comme quoi tu vas tu joues ton jeu avec
pour yan tu joues un coup
et tu provoques la pleutrerie
bon c'est par où adam mais c'est que là
on peut venir que de la position c'est
clairement un coup tu joues pour faire
annuler tout est changé donc ça peut te
repondre aujourd'hui ça va prendre aux
turbos trader n'a pas du tout aussi de
réfuter la loge non il a pris peur mais
oui mais parce qu'il se dit on va jouer
trois 3 lopez 3 nuls et pourquoi je
risquais je rentre à damas à chaque fois
que m mais ok faut arrêter les joueuses
on verra 5 kw est ce tellement de
recréer pour yann quand même
après dans un autre situation tout il
joue pas demain je sais mais tu sens
quand même que c'était pas loin enfin
bon heureusement n'est pas fini le matin
je sais je sais mais tu sens que tu te
mets quand même bien dans la merde tout
seul comme rihanna justin si je joue un
peu mon jeu mais je pense qu'il a juste
des fonds s'était second temps là quand
tu viens ça te détendre hunting cours
non
finances du précariat kinch et des fonds
soient déjà pour te détendre mentalement
et tu reviens avec faire le plein
d'énergie
et tu joues d'autres trucs après quoi il
a ajouté qu ou quad et que tu joues tu
es coup ils craquent en face
ric rac when i veut il veut assurer quoi
il veut pas jouer
les termes d'un message royal juste pas
d'idée non pas des changes tout
tu bouffes la dame vraiment pas deuxième
tour mais 5
sur 24 six ou g6 cette rechute un fou 3
juste bouffe
fort chaque échec ouais au bout tu
flashes cadre
révisé change pour ça
tu pensé vraiment ça l'idée assez d'une
pleutrerie
sur ses solides
à lui
non c'est une très belle partie fab
magnifique à le h5 de yann voilà qui
mettait en danger le magnus carlsen
attaqué par un pion quand même qu'ils
venaient quand même s'approcher du roi
et donc tout de suite là bien réagi il a
échangé la faim énorme réaction du
champion du monde dames 1 pour échanger
les dames est vraiment tout liquider
immédiatement il ne laisse aucune chance
à yann nepomniachi une partie fabien
vraiment de très haut niveau aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on la reverra dans les
manuels dans les écoles d'échecs pour
des décennies je pense qu'ils ont réfuté
ils ont réfuté la petrov aujourd'hui
c'était une partie une partie historique
une partie d'anthologie exceptionnel
ils ont été également un petit peu
limité par le temps de réflexion fable
pour trouver ces coûts dont une partie
longue il ya deux jours dont une partie
de 8h ya deux jours et là
malheureusement un freiner magnus 5 45
minutes malgré tout ils trouvent le
ku'damm 1
sera ordinaire
performance yann qui revient pas
s'asseoir on sent qu'il est dans le dur
il a besoin de récupérer après ce coup
de butoir quand même et malgré l'arrivée
d'une dame en sept minutes avoir échangé
les dames et filer à la nulle
bacon bel échange la colonne une belle
position bien symétrique comme on les
aime et c'est vrai que le joueur
norvégien
éclabousse de son talent ces
championnats du monde on se rappelle la
partie qu'il a gagné il ya deux jours
fabien zéro erreur une partie digne des
plus grands
coups de fil blanc cousu de fil blanc
avec une ouverture des nouvelles idées
apportées aux échecs ses joueurs
révolutionne le jeu à chacune de leurs
sorties dans des parties haletante au
rythme effréné
c'est vraiment magnifique fabien et on
voit un yann qui en train d'essayer de
sortir des shots qui essayent de
déverrouiller la porte mais le verrou
qui reste bloqué à y arriver
il aura réussi lui resté une heure et
demie pour pour déverrouiller mais ça
lui a suffit simplement une petite
dizaine de minutes c'est vrai qu'à ce
niveau de la compétition fabien les
joueurs ne restent plus enfermer non ils
savent sortir ils ont bien suivi pour
fort boyard sans ressort et il a sorti
il restait une heure et demie simplement
une heure et demie à la clepsydre fabien
il a réussi à sortir et la mandriva
pouvoir réfléchir une petite demi-heure
pour bien-être sur d'échanger les dames
fabien
c'est bon
on sait pas on peut faire un fou aussi
son peut faire un roi y fit faut cinq
peut-être faudra vite est fou et cinq
petites bombes placées pour le piège de
magnus titrait même page et de prendre
tout de suite derrière qui pourrait
continuer par un coup comme s quatre
pattes bien sûr de prendre le faut ouais
donc bon déjà ça faudra éviter un
premier piège tendu par magnus c'est
vrai que ce coût est beaucoup plus
venimeux qu'il n'y semblait
d'avoir après peut-être fou hausse est
bon c'est partir n ont plus de rouge et
la même pièce a déjà déjà un peu mieux
déjà un peu mieux pris aussi fois ci
soit bien fou aussi ça pour le coup je
crois comprendre le bélier avec le bref
c'est vraiment dur avoir vraiment dur
avoir sondé tard la structure quand même
mais bon si c'est pour la gagner un fou
est-ce que ça suffit pas bien un fou
contre une structure détériorer si joue
dame 17e' scipion f5 et grand roque pour
jouer l' attaquent à fond aïe c'est une
position que ma nièce a dû évaluer
pendant de longues minutes
c'est décidé sûrement et de la pensée
comme étant favorable
jusqu'à longue réflexion et
ça me ferait pas tous ceux qui jusque là
voir tous ces deux trois coups de plus
pour être bien sûr alors pour nous c'est
quand même beaucoup plus facile
puisqu'on regard quand même avec l'aide
de l'ordinateur on a les évaluations
fabien qui nous permettent de bien
comprendre ces coups-là roi et fuite
intéressant
mais bon peut-être fou b4
pour bien échangé le fou de cases noires
et se dire bon leur aurait fui tijane un
peu les tours alors est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer par la suie 3,8 puis
grand roc va bien alors c'est
malheureusement interdit
quand on a brûlé leur en veut plus
rauque est
terrible règles mais
et les joueurs sont au courant oui pas
normalement sont au courant de de ces
points épineux de règlement les arbitres
sont toujours là vont veiller au cra
fabien même s'ils sont discrets on les
voit pas trop mais bon je pense qu'ils
doivent rodez comme des aigles au tour
et sont prêts à la moindre irrégularité
est ce que petit rock sur un coup ici
pour aller cacher le roi et gagner du
temps elle en veut on est sûr à chaque
pas le droit donc encore un point de
règlement se fait beaucoup de règlements
la faudra photo différents j'espère que
les arbitres sont la liane
doit être au courant de ces règles là
mais bon à voir et dont il reste à 27 le
couple qui prédisaient fabien le coup
donné par par les machines un coup
vraiment difficile à trouver
tu mets la dame en face du roi et
peut-être d'amener un retour on se roule
essayé deux hommes d'élite retour 8 pour
cela du magnifique
mais sur dame 7 way peut-être d'un
programme et donc est donc une tour qui
viendrait remettre un échec
les tours qui s'échangera sur la colonne
pour faire une nulle rapide yann qui
réfléchit quand même hein ce coude à
main est venu vraiment comme une épée de
damoclès
au dessus de sa tête au roi chute
incroyable et ils joueront f8 fabien
incroyable il ne rêvons pas faire nul
extraordinaire ça fait huit îlots pèse
quoi et tu fais roi fit
d'aller très énervé n'est pas quand il
va absolument pas de la ville
on va avoir fourbi 4 j'imagine
il veut jouer pour gagner il est très
très chaud ce
magnifique incroyable ah c'est peut-être
la plus belle partie du tournoi la
extraordinaire
j'adore
il va juste être moins bien
mais a très bien joué et coûterait 20
psychologique
pousse son adversaire dans ses derniers
retranchements il le pousse à la faute
après run fuite
mais tu penses c'est un truc qu'on a pas
vu non mais y aura foule et 4 et puis
2007 est juste un peu moins bien sans
raison
à bab souika de ces partis c'est
extraordinaire mais je pense qu'il va
faire de 9,6
bonsoir finale 5 0
l'adar depuis elle n'a quand même pas
exagérer
et
écoute très beau sur dame 7 6 7 1
après bien sûr
[Rires]
la neige tombera en fait la partie
aujourd'hui c'est n'importe quoi
je vais une vidéo récap les mêmes
analyses ouais c'est plusieurs sur
youtube de faire du travail comme ça
comment peuvent-ils se permettre
ben non mais leur maîtresse a
en fait ce ne serait plus vraiment finir
en une heure et demie quoi
reda me 7 mais c'est stupide en fait un
échange les [ __ ] cases noires
l'usr non mesdames dir il fait la moue
cette
v4 dams est maintenant
pourquoi des recettes directes
by peut-être un truc bon après ça peut
être très grave ou de même couleur
mais oui enfin très honnêtement sans
rigoler si tu as la même partie en 3 + 0
non même pas oui mais en fait c'est le
pardon 3 + 0 quant à tielt et de prendre
sa défaite d'affilée à damas où tu
essaies de faire lecture de soirée et
qu'il est chez paquet leur
puisqu'en fait fédéraux f8
je suis déjà au taquet femmes
5,0
et encore franchement j'avais pu être un
jour à mener
attention une menace a quand même failli
c'est fou pro b 4 oui mais ça va voir
aller la voir
bon voilà
bon il peut tout est changé quoi c'est
bien
les chansons échange tous ont fait une
petit nul non on peut toujours renverser
à cette option
je suis obligé faire deux trois
trucs bah oui avant de le recevoir
ça ne fait pas peur
[Musique]
c'est saint-etienne perdre 5-0 à
domicile contre rennes
ces plaisirs convient le dimanche tous à
plus de franchement les leurs parmi
c'était pas si mal
tm quoi puis je prends un but de buts 3
buts étaient menés 3 à la mi temps et
alors après chaque semaine tombait quoi
sa
mort et la vie du doigt je te dire ouais
moi j'étais pas mal non là c'est pas mal
c'était juste 20 minutes mais après ça a
été
catastrophique
j'ai les jeux en démonstration
exactement une belle petite équipe
rennes ça bouge ça je t'avais dit avant
cannes cet effort moi je vois pas mal de
live sur mon truc assuré que j'ai écrit
des trucs de satellites y apparaît j'ai
pas mal de l'ail
lorientais anticipé quoi blige
la vie de tarifs entrées dans 3 2 1
tab bon pour sainté quoi dans la stéréo
minable
rayonner qu'il ait et whitney je crois
pas mamie à des stéphanois qui lie pour
toulon on veut pas des méchants
est ce possible de faire un parallèle
entre certaines époux
dépôt c'est beaucoup mieux et magnus
n'empêche qu'il a confirmé la règle 48
de réflexion coup de merde oui messieurs
je vous tenez les paumés
il bat troyes pour continuer c'est le
couple leur dise quoi
qu'il fasse il peut faire hein c'est pas
du tout mais quatre tu pourras b dames
1er tour ouais c'est un poids de chiens
un poil
je peux pas comprendre en fait
nan là le niveau de jeu c'est un ami non
c'est très très fort et souvent
me croyais pas faire dame 7 c'est
costaud quand même un fourneau 6
je ne sais prend
non mais en fait juste fait d'armé cette
dirais que c'est juste et égale ainsi je
peux pas faire ça c'est vu que je peux
pas comprendre
qu est ce que tu peux rater en fait
très tôt pour aller vite c'est vraiment
un coup
même vous prendrez 6 en faites quoi tu
vois pas à trois
dames prendre un fou prend des six on va
peut-être s'est passé graphique à tarbes
et 6 à 5 mais bon tu te forces à un tour
dû prendre à distance via prè
wallon mais magnus clients de
rothschild
mais il reste un poil mieux magnus
ouais mais attend il ya toujours huit
après tout raciste ou blessés ça mais
bon ton contre garde h5
assez sûr qu'ils rien mais
met fin à un juste niveau tu peut
égaliser sans vraiment aucun effort je
trouve à dire c'est des efforts un petit
peu même dame g5
pas vite ses trajets avec en vue la
semaine une dimension qu'on peut pas
comprendre en fait
c'est vraiment mesquin piquemal
championnats du monde ce qui est bien
c'est que la même les ordis comprennent
pas en fait la dimension au débat c'est
vraiment au dessus non non c'est un
peut-être le plus beau match de
l'histoire en fait ça joue à cinq mille
lots je pense
minimum mignonne
mais là c'est du tilt un dépôt car la
scène c'est la peur et les poster le
tilt mais bon on my ne faut pas juste
une pression comme ça en fait c'est
bizarre en fait c'est juste il sait qui
peut pas perdre impossible et tu as un
petit avantage il va quand même te la
jouer il va pas tout est changé par
plaisir tout échanger et donc s'il peut
te faire souffrir et finalement gagner
un truc il n'imagine même pas gagné lui
mais
voilà
je sais pas mais ça on va me dire que
c'est extraordinaire ou quoi même fait
je passe pas des heures dans match du
monde pour des partis comme ça enfin là
vraiment je vois deux 2004 jouer
ouais même pas en fait
t'as pas besoin là là je sais pas tu vas
voir ça tout le temps n'importe où même
mouais mais ma 18900 ces parties là pour
l'instant après tu es vraiment il faudra
trouver des coûts
et montons matériau est vraiment
extraordinaire enfin
aux affaires g620t
alors j'essaie d'être vite mais bon j
estime la fia thrill veut tomber tu es
un peu ça sera mérité comme ça
tu es
13 50 m c'est un avantage des blancs ce
qui est fou de gaza tu prends de
l'espace tu bloques le fou 17 donne des
gages sûreté tour
3 de 13,6 un jour donc
triple peiné nous dit dès 1500 envie de
rejouer la même mais vraiment en fait
et on dirait que ça joue mal
on attend le mans
ce que damon et non mesdames heurte à
l'uci non mesdames mais en fait on
comprend pas c'est juste pas un bon coup
on soit c'est dans la situation du match
entre la situation du match du match ça
va c'est bon final il n'y a aucune
partie décorrélé de situation
donc
des rois fuite spectaculaire comme
en fait juste ça dégoûte
c'est la partie était pas connu ce qu'il
veut faire un gaz de lots et tu vas
jamais donné
on va voir la suite mais pour l'instant
prêtresse coup
je suis au compteur depuis le début leur
but c'est le titre n'est pas de rentrer
dans la légende c'est comme dans
d'autres sports l'intéressant c'est la
qualification pour les quarts et demi
finales sauf qu aux échecs n'ont en fait
de quoi les matches championnat il dit
que les plus intéressants c'est pas les
finales du championnat du monde que là
c'est maintenant
ça dépend a eu beaucoup de beaux matchs
championnat du monde aux échecs oui il
me soit même dans les autres sports en
mai un grand chelem c'est quand même le
tapis
même des finales de coupe du monde au
foot un débat à la fin je parlais de
france brésil 80 18 ans fait match très
abouti de la france
ben c'était pas mal comme si ton sortie
quoi
et brésil italie la de
10 le brésil sera envoyé à coiffer un
jardin des équipes qui en finale là où
c'est le plus du temps dû être sorti le
gros match dans des foyers de sont
tendus des fois ça arrive je sais
un peu quand on demande le plus moche de
tennis peut-être
ce sexy ya beaucoup de gens qui ont de
citer federer nadal finale de wimbledon
2008 final
ça arrive que des belles finales je sais
que des fois les gens sont très attendus
ou quoi et ça ça arrive aussi bien sûr
et des belles finales et on a beaucoup
voir des fois on a un qui fait de belles
finales et l'autre qui est trop tendue
qui se fait déchirer
magic france et bien sûr français jeu
samedi la france a bien joué avec le
brésil s'était pas ou font qu'on ne le
doigté pas dans son état l'argentine
allemagne n'était pas terrible non plus
non j'en avais une série et atteint 814
c'était nul suffit aux tirs au but à 90
et un penalty mais bon 86 pas si mal et
ça dépend des années évidemment je sais
france télé 2006
pas bons souvenirs
ça dépend
oui mais on y voir poule bongo à la fin
vous retrouver plein il ya des bonnes et
des moins bonnes mais donc c'est pas
obligé que ce soit mal tout le temps ça
veut dire en fait
un bon match mais en fait le truc
bizarre auquel score était éclatant je
n'ai pas trop de la france a fait un si
bon match
jusqu'à ce penalty
plutôt les croates qui domine
impassible connais pas préparé une
semaine spéciale pour gagner à la fin
en fait s'il peut aussi payer le frais
d'équipement
benzema tendance wafa bailly perfore
et
sa place en équipe de france après le
seul défaut que je peux venir deschamps
dans la fed a repris benzema c'est la
reprise si tard
quant au rachis soir mais ça tourne déjà
partis tard c'est que ça a changé la
manière de jeu de l'équipe un peu plus
offensif etc sachant ton très offensif
et à l'euro on n'était pas quelle
attitude lynette elle commence à
s'affoler un trio non
plus un mais beaucoup c'est incroyable
ce n'est pas
mérité ouais on va voir
damien saddam hussein devait y avoir une
idée c'est pas possible je pense pas
allez je vous dire ça
elle vous contrôler savait que la
turbine est
un entourage qui se voulait être une
idée que j'avais mais juste comme la
turbie net s'enflamme je viens ici pour
moi j'imagine que ça va mais un juge me
pose des questions je vais faire ça me
paraissait six femmes toutes questionne
le gazole puisque juste les coûts
naturel s'ils sont bons joueurs absents
que j'aurais mieux joué en bullet quoi
et flipper donné un bon bol cook là on
se donne soit
on met juste c'est évident faire ainsi
20 7
euros 16 va faire ça à faire nul bref it
tu te mahmoud 0,30 deux fois l'écart de
score s'est pas encore assez grave même
les 00 02 hockey c'est très bonne heure
c'était vraiment fini oui maintenant je
vais d amère mais j'ai pas internet bon
bref 8,4
au maire comme air
très vite
je suis bon
scheer mais la mire et blanc est même un
peu mieux les blancs
partie
assez famélique un numéro 90
nécessaire
il veut échanger va faire tourner leur
tour est vite fait huit tours et il te
dit que surtout aussi ce que tu veux
faire ça va pas s'y être progressiste
upa prendre balade à monsieur dame b 4
échecs il ya pas de match le staff ou
iphone et si tu prends de f tu te fous
dans la mer des dames g5 c'est ce que
j'avais vu en plus c'est
ce que j'avais compris
donc
voilà en fait si les blancs ton tour
l'un 20 boucles tourquennoises envie de
faire tu vas faire tour aussi longue
date orages 6 génial et les blancs de te
faire dame g5 et peut-être des petits
trucs et venir de tourner autour et
tours 5 aussi quand même 5 outre 500
tours 5 parce que l'on ait fait d'alger
5 direct qui est peut-être bien joué ici
un bon c'est pas mal hein tu veux
rentrer dans les cases où il ya un peu
des trous
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment dire que jamais quoi bon c'est
très bien comme justin c'est peut-être
un peu moins bien que ce qu'on a vu
juste avant mais ça reste un coût normal
qui mobilise la tour 1 h 6
donc il peut pas faire son plan de tir
de fer h4 était de faire des coups comme
ça je sais pas
mais ces petites pressions blanche en
fait non mais c'est juste de rien du
tout ça passe à sa vue c'est rien du
tout c'est même pas dur à trouver les
copains c'est juste rien du tout avec
les coups les plus simples du monde
en fait même un joueur à 16 100 du
crédit
ben moi j'ai un élève qui me fait
horreur et fit jeudi c'est n'importe
quoi
et là bon être il avoue être
complètement en débutant jeudi c'est de
la merde
tu vas mais là n'est pas fort qu'ils
jouent bien
s'est pas perdu tous essayé de ne pas un
truc de ouf mais
mais c'est agaçant
de voir ça
absents direction dizaines d'appels en
absence d'un nouveau super de plus un
nouveau supplément vas-tu allait
téléphoner
ça rappelle
[Musique]
moi je pense une prestation
proche de celle de synthés
koala
est juste décevant parce qu'en fait
c'est incompréhensible c'est un tilt
c'est pas une question d'être pour les
peaux pour carlson nous voilà c'est
juste que que magnus gagnant sera tant
mieux pour lui là là sur cette partie et
ce sera mérité mais juste en fait
j'ai du mal à me dire que tu as gagné
une partie
enfin tu penses que je veux dire
jusque là le niveau de jeu droite aurait
pu gagner au blanc un savoir comment ça
va jouer derrière mais tu peux gagner là
même où l'on a pour l'instant nous n'en
avons plus c'est ça ce qu'on veut ne pas
départi de 8 heures pour
la même c'est du rapide en fait même ses
publicités critique même endroit plus
sain t critique là
c'est super mais je le dame un oui de
demain est très mal joué mais en fait le
roi ait fuité encore pierre hommes et
ravageuse c'est pas le meilleur que la
position de loin magnus le savez est un
peu dégoûté de jouer ça mais bon il sait
qu'il est peut être en faisant mais il
fait plus très clair m6 mène 1-0 dans le
match et se dit ok mais on en fait pas
de risque on s'en fou
juste n'est pas la merde en tira jc
salut sinon ça hallucinant mais il
comprend peut être que c'est de la merde
bah oui mais mais pourquoi rapide
à en fait je peux pas trop critiquer ce
qui va
me fait rien en fait c'est un truc peut
être éclairer sait rien en fait c'est
pas mal c'est y mène au score ils
puissent ont choisi du nul ont
maintenant maintenant il va pas de faire
comme ça ça fait penser à djoko qui
tenait alors certainement dans les
échanges justice arrête de taper fort
mais il trouve une balle quoi
donner une balle à taper
sur le ventre et quart pour la
reconnaître au commissarait mais
hélas niveau c'est pas du tout agréable
comme position
pas du tout agréable parce que il va pas
pouvoir bien contester la seule colonne
ouverte de l'échiquier la colonne à
l'arc les blancs ne peuvent échanger des
tours et mètres la tour eiffel voilà
donc la tour qui en rouge blanc h6 peut
pas venir participer à perdre ce match 5
donc après on peut penser à des trucs à
dire oui mais si tu prends h5 je reviens
h6 égard démâtage de rmc que non at on
pourra échanger les tours
et revenir c'est ça
doit prendre lundi à damas suite à tout
va dans les deux sens
d'agdam 5 donc on a gagné un pion et
surtout reprend bien qu'ils sont gaming
tour il ya dans la chute rôles sept
soldats ont récupéré tournon encore un
point de plus et peut-être d'autres g7
donc
bon voilà donc on va être la tourache 6
elle est pourrie quoi tu as été le 9 on
a aussi semé peut pas donc elle est là
pour faire le plot et magnus suivent ce
sera la colonne eux la tourelle peut
venir en cinq peut-être un moment il
peut doubler tour il peut renforcer
machin etc juste chiant éclaireurs donc
pas assez grave pour berne pour un ordi
mais tu te retrouves en discuter votre
des coups précis et tu sais plus trop
comment tu te débrouilles qu'elle
[Musique]
soit ils échangent fait s'échanger mai
on dira qu à fond de l'espace
je bouge trois choses les plus de danger
5,08 ont échangé les tours puis en
échange la deuxième est sénile
instantanée sans aucun alors là le
pirate cinq ont pu le toucher donc il à
votre instinct et crache ses atouts veut
s'en fout mais c'est pas dur en fait
enfin c'est vraiment un coup qu'on
aurait joué en bulles à 9,6 là bas c'est
super conduire à 88 jusqu'où donc donc
faire broyer fit faut avoir une bonne
raison mais bien d'ailleurs même pas
l'ombre d'une raison
ya rien à dire quoi va surtout faire
face à tout coup d'après
donc c'est que juste
bas mérité un but du coup je sais
mais c'est assez hallucinant
ce cas c'est plus une question d' échec
c'est juste
je sais pas
sain mais la cbi
c'était juste envie de perdre comme en
fait quand tu fais ça
concernant
ce qu'en fait je comprends tu te [ __ ]
dans la merde pour une potion très
compliqué et que ses chances de gain
silo german mais quand tu peux le dire
avec les blancs ça
non vraiment là le niveau de l'épaule
jusque là oui c'est mille huit cents
lots je sais pas ce que ça quoi
mais howard après peut-être qu'il va se
finir porte bien de la défense de fer
quand même nul ou je sais pas c'est
juste se mettre mal par plaisir se
mettre maintenant
week end ils adorent ce que vous y
mettez dans les regards les coûts en
fait je sais pas assez
ça c'est vraiment comme si au foot tu es
à deux contre un face à un goal seul et
que je sais pas depuis de cire trois
mètres au dessus en fait plusieurs fois
et plusieurs fois mais je suis pas là
c'est vraiment
fou non royal fuite c'est juste l'une
heures c'est une erreur là pas
d'explication
mais c'est nerveux un laçage c'est pas
espagne fasse paniquer son niveau de jeu
à huit ans il joue mieux que ça hamhuis
a enfin pu si d'autres n'avaient de
lui-même la
place et
il n'y a pas d'explication rationnelle à
ce genre de choix ascom le fou prend
bekkat encore un peu plus compréhensible
vous prouvez 4 mais là c'est vraiment
lent mais là ya zéro explication peut
pas être échiquier 1 comme explication
c'est forcément un gros craquage quoi
énorme gaffe mais dans l'esprit ça fait
quand même partie 1 il ya des gars que
tu rates pas ce que tu fais une faute de
calcul là le roi et fit fable c'est
quand même c'est costaud quand même en
termes d'évaluation c'est pas la plus
grosse faute bien évident bien
évidemment mais en terme de connerie que
tu peux faire sur un jugement
mais je sais pas ce qu'il a jugé jeu là
je peux même pas expliquer la connerie
au vote
comme dame au cash flow expliquait
d'ailleurs
qu'il a reconnu lui même en oui mais là
c'est encore plus gros placer mes pas me
casser une position où je sais pas
l'actualité du jeu avant tout sur deux
ait notamment là en fait c'est juste eu
ça ça depuis qu'on a appris les échecs
en fait
les cinq ans il a pas jusqu'où
non mais c'est vrai
c'est bizarre
bah c'est dommage parce qu'on pourra
voir un beau match championnat du monde
enfin peu de dynepo tu tiens là tu
l'envoies un truc un peu douter
ou pas mais
c'est toujours pareil perdre combien
gagnent plus fort toi quand il joue
mieux que toi
bravo à mieux jouer était plus fort
perdre tout seul ça va toujours un
regret quant à l' hyper tout seul
de 15 a
revu fab boudjellal
elle fait du bien cette pub
la salle avait vraiment les autres elles
il y avait une compréhension avait
quelque chose derrière le dam leca t
dame prend h4 c'était une mauvaise
décision mais il y avait une décision là
le roi est fluide ces mêmes flux l'ombre
d'une explication en fait
c'est juste n'importe quoi c'est de
vraiment voir le tour h6 qua
non mais
j'ai plein cintre et orages 6 bon bah du
coup je ferais fit gens sans dire
quand on regarde l'analyse fuite est un
excellent quoi apparemment
c'est un coup deux coups en fait
en fait ce n'est juste tu mets l'ordi en
fait d'accord il va me dire qu'ils te
dis à ma façon t'as pas cinquante coups
en feintant rigola tas a pas beaucoup de
coûts légaux en fait t'as dams est ta
phu aussi ce
fou hausse est ta phu au 5 et 1 réfute
ontex cinq coups possibles en fait bon
faux seins vous avez compris que c'est
de la merde ça donne à fond dans sa
série mini faut aussi c'est de la merde
aussi avec 4
et ça perd quasiment sur le champ bon
éliminé donc as 3 cuil à soupe de cette
basse et à ses katas en fait parce que
on recule ce fouillis les passifs les
blancs on pouvoir doubler sur la colonne
peut-être jésus dames 5 du fou les 4
enfin
si vous voyez pas je sais pas quoi dire
en fête est alors y as trois fuites et
des recettes on a beau s'être il va
échanger dame en force
prendre durand responsable sheikh on va
cacher le roi à ce moment là est tout le
problème qu'on a dans ce qu'on explique
à coeur c'est tout rachid qui joue pas
parce que le curage 5 est en prison et
doivent pas la ramener bon mais là en
fait on va faire tout 8 on va la ramener
quoi et puis puis passe rien c'est
symétrique voyez bien qui a pas une
menace qui aime on peut faire les normes
pas faire grand chose non plus ça va
être échangé changent et changent et
point final alors quand vous en aurez
fit donc et le deuxième couple vers la
pression pour le coup sur cinq s'est pas
non plus bas on se dire 'ok on n'a pas
échangé les dames par des problèmes les
blancs vont fouler 4 bat c'est hyper
logique moi je pensais qu'on allait
faire foudre et sera forfait quatre sont
pas changés toutes pièces dans ce bon
food & wine food et 6 il n'a pas de foot
de pions sur sa couleur regarderai
endroit vers h2 et faire des trucs donc
on les charge en force bon ben il fait
dams est maintenant si on me prend et
c'est la même position sauf cas les
dames sur l'échiquier en d2 en
distribuer des fous est pas la dame elle
vient là bas je viens advienne chiante
3,8 taurin
tourache six fois ci le doublé est
d'alger 500 différence par rapport à un
fou ça attaque h5 donc si plus dur là
donc on peut tu as ensuite c'est clair
que c'est moins 20 de cette version
comparer d'opposition ça se voit en fait
et si on dit non c'est qu'on vient de la
mauvaise foi des supers du lauzet shine
je sais pas ça c'est aussi possible mais
voilà
c'est incroyable c'est vraiment très
très simple à voir donc
extrêmement simple
et sans compter que il ya non seulement
cette erreur là mais par là
j'imagine qu'il y avait des idées avec
des jets 6,3 g 7 pour d'autres murs mais
déjà c'est moins simple mais oui pardon
est probablement mieux que toi je sois
je me disais ag six f4
bon on peut mettre 5 soit 3 de chant
déjà mieux près blanche
j'ai même pas envie d'analysé parce
qu'en fait c'est tellement des coûts de
merde pour les noirs fait rencontrer
mais maintenant je répète oui car ça y
est cette partie s'est pas fait parce
que l'avantagé n'est pas si grand en
fait sa une position symétrique à +12
une pièce sur l'échiquier on va pas maté
mais ce truc car ça ne fait bien quoi
d'accumuler petit avantage
après la tête un peu de volume n'est pas
allé
non mais s'il fait nul
ne sait pas ce que je souhaite pour
cette partie en fait dans cette partie
géré avec des bots perde et soit puni
mais ça tue le match alors pour
l'intérêt du match sur un jeu qui
perdent pas
mais ça peut encore tenir parce que
c'était tellement égal
avec une erreur ça ne m'est pas perdant
perdant
on va voir
du coup évidemment sa place dans une
partie en balance avec des grands devant
des grosses attaques ça va être ça entre
en finale vers des petits détails ne
tourne mal placé une petite menace par
ci par là
que les gens comprennent pas c'est que
tu as me 7 c'est trop facile ici car
c'est un peu poussé à écrire des menaces
en voit qu'une once de difficultés de
risque
de perdre c'est ça ouais c'est quand
même tu peux la loue et six heures en
fait tout à l'heure c'était 95% nuls et
cinq courses entre deux victoires d'un
côté ou de l'autre là c'est 80% nuls et
20 % de défaite
les événements davis et que dans un sens
et tu donnes de chansons adversaires
on va voir
worth ministre des idées d'ailleurs a
fléchi bas maintenant ils cherchent
vraiment en fait là c'est pas une
réflexion pour le gamin a peut-être que
ceux ci c'est le mercure
a dit chris
huhne en soit le mal est fait maintenant
à voir kiss est en mode qui jouent tous
les meilleurs coucheront pas perdre
bref je doute pas que nous son mesure
sur son talent enrichi qu'un de tenir
cette position mais
viennent jouer avant et possiblement
dans quel état il est
juste à carson en face je devrais
peut-être le meilleur joueur possible
pour jouer ce genre de truc contre toi
donc fait y'a rien qui va quoi
on va voir
le truc ce fait c'est quoi je vois dans
talent pour ségolène n'est pas joue ça
parce qu'il veut pas de nunes et qui
vient du projet mais en fait ils jouent
pas ils se retrouvent en position
défensive il n'y a toujours pas de
chance de gagner ça peut arriver que des
fonds ont fait exprès de faire des coups
un peu bizarre comme son âge cinq ans
fait
dangereux mais pour créer une
incertitude est
ok on sait qu'on a peut-être que 10% de
chances de bien c'est toujours mieux que
zéro là il y en a pas de chance de bien
c'est même pas ça la raison qui aurait
pu être compréhensible objectivement pas
bonne mais bon peu importe son pote
objectif en pratique on doit pas faire
des choses et
c'est c'est pas genre de parties qu'on a
qu'on a envie de voir en championnat du
monde clairement femmes
dans ce qui se passe
voici joue trop de lignes ont un ordi
jusqu'à la fin alors 10 et ira quand
même je suis d'accord mais probablement
c'est quand même un gros aux fils ted
strickland on devait vraiment bien alors
de base ont joué juste norman un peu
tous
avisé le tient avec
si je veux juste faire un nul voire le
moment avec les noirs ben non là c'est
parce qu'on ne peut pas faire mieux sans
vraiment s'y magnus un tilt mais je vois
pas comment c'est possible de voir
édition
mais on a du mal à trouver des belles
games pour le moment
on a du mal à trouver de belles games et
et celle là pas les retards donc il a
pris 1,8 ouais bah il va faire le truc à
8,8
mais je pense qu'il veut tout un drame
f6 essayer de
la dame mais là faut pas les changer la
donne
dans l'histoire d'anne decis
d'ailleurs dam des deux dames d'ici mais
ouais donc j'ai troisième des six
taureaux 5
à temps plein de
médias moyens d'embêter je ne sais pas
ces frais si on va vraiment bien
jacqueline a
réparti que vous avez compté gagner
franchement les blancs d'avoir ça c'est
déjà super une petrov donc la sauce pas
se rendre
et cesser donne combien
contre naniwa reprend 8 s'est relevé
méthodes qu'il est très serein autour 1
s'était jouée en tout cas en magnus et
on va voir la drc mans s'est il fait
daniel système g3 dans des histoires aux
500 de 0,37 c'est pas énorme on va voir
on n'est pas doit être précis c'est pas
encore alarmant c'est juste la table
comme il avait jusque-là
hypothèse n'est pauvres que manu se
fatigue en cherchant un lien et demain
il le turbo in avec les blancs à ben
voilà c'est ça en fait la strate de
donner vos défauts on n'avait pas
compris femmes à se rater pas mal mais
malheureusement demain sur notre peau
donc ça tombe à l'eau en fait peut-être
qui sait pas que ces
strates mais qui va être remis en cause
par le rythme du tournoi et le règlement
interne quoi c'est une sera si courait
souvent football de laisser deux buts à
l'adversaire davance
première monte à monterrey
a cédé belle sera atteint
mais enfin je pense qu'il est capable
d'être là de se remettre et je voulais
bon bah il est en train de jouer les
bons coups
[Musique]
mais en fait ça se trouve c'est
tellement simple pour lui notre doussain
mais je suis pas sûr enfin
la dernière fois
sur un match de toute beauté
bon simon hughes venu du froid dame
prendra mais ils sont fous fin de la
partie estime ainis de s'embêter un peu
ils valent à reculer
la strate de sainté en ligue 1 c'est ça
ça marche pas trop je peux vous le dire
semblant toi tu penses qu'on vous le
maintien
détrompe toi c'est pas c'est pas le
strat de jeunes
époux les conseils stratégiques chez
movistar
s'est tellement ça la movistar iran
tellement fou fab
plus tard
on va voir un psy maggie se veut drôle
je pense pas
je ferais pas sa place mais bon il m'a
pas leurs chais pas franchement la
partie mme
[Musique]
bellavance à mon adversaire sur un 100
mètres pour mieux le rattraper
c'est magnifique
j'aurais tort de ne pas la jouer là
n'est pas fait pour lui filer âme ça
c'est sûr qu'il va la jouer on rigole un
peu un
homme f11 sondage 4,6
être trop petit caprice prise tout
réussi c'est la finale de ouais c'est
trop petit
moi j'aurais pas eu peur mais bon ceux
d'alger 3 vraiment regarder d'en prendre
quatre mois je
ne veux pas de lien direct
parce que demain 8 tours au cices
allons peu beauf robe de satin
sûr qu'on est mieux
même pas mieux
ouais
et donc donc oui il faudrait être fou f5
aventure réussissent à le laisser
là type
d'affaires tarifs 6
c'est la merde by ap adam prendre qu'à
moi
du coup faire damer g3 très clairement
si dame prenait 4 sur ses cimaises à
dire ta dam dam des six taureaux 500 a
vu tout à l'heure que c'était cool
tour de défendre plus la dame alors
bon soin va cherche là dedans soit il
fait un truc comme ça
ça va plus dans l'échangé un peu tour il
peut essayer de tourner un peu là-dessus
là un poil mieux un poil valait mieux
nommer m
mais bon
ouais je pense qu'on va te refiler ses
cadres des trucs la mort non mais ces
votes nuls d'accord
il faut prendre sûrement si je fais ces
cinq 05 ça concède vraiment menaçants
c'est pas sûr
parce que je vais faire à quatre baies 5
je vais faire b si je me dis qu'on
assiste je ne sais qu'un v6 3,6 à chaque
fois et je peux rentrer avec laura là
bas
ça pas de tenir bon mais là on a géré
plus normé juste pour dire bon il peut
aussi un truc comme ça sinon vie je vais
faire b52 base d'un
homme ça doit aller ça
je bois trop compères saint clément au
dessus ça une bonne vision du monde je
connais bien mais c'est tout
acheté à 3 ans s'offre à nous avec une
tête qui allaient à craindre car pas mal
mais d'alger 3 pts est le coup le plus
fort
bond après
un coup
près de la célèbre mollusque peut faire
ses petits coups qui savent pas grand
chose un petit c3 un petit coup de pion
à je crois qu'il a du mal à ranger tu
joueras saïda tourage 6 avons peut-être
chiffres f4 f5 bien taille mais je sais
pas en fait
c voilà pour moi ça je le bats pas
contre mais bon je sais déjà mais
aussi peut faire
cette aura qui s'est même placé
soit il veut se faire un peu mal et a
déjoué ça soit il est ok ça on s'en fout
j'échange les dames ça serait étonnant
oui
madame c'est sûr quand même si tu
rentres dans sa chambre d'hôtel oui
on a vote ok c'est un coup qu'on n'a pas
regardé mais dans le genre d'idée on
regarde les dames
vous faisiez cette prime
le fou est attaqué alors sinon l'autre
où seraient d'amd 8 mai passif
avait coûté 7 a envie que toute façon il
est mal placé tu leur place
et plus que naturel
très naturel
oui mais bon en lui et pas trop dur à
pourquoi at il ne fait pas là je la fin
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui nous fait me glisse
ensuite
mais le seul défaut que là c'est qu'on a
pas 12000 quoi jouer quoi j'ai 6 ans et
moins bientôt faire rager cet orage
suite machin mais on ne font plus la
tour la dame de rester
072 n'y a pas de menace directe mais bon
à l'étape sont pas grand chose de fou 17
mai il toujours mieux en 17 points 8
pour mieux contrôler une diagonale ou
t'as pas de pions dont on est que
la presse eut à faire d'anne decis
un
poil juste mais ça a l'air de passer non
savoir si un nul comme ça s'apprend pas
une partie trop longue ça laisse un
suspense dans le match
qui fasse autre chose
étonnant
si l'un d'eux savoir trop quoi raconter
sur ses parties
c'est vrai que ces dlc
des échecs étrange femme
pour ne pas dire autrement
c'est vrai que si ces mêmes c'était du
rapide on serait étonné
meublaient des fins écologiques sûrement
de laisser naviguer la dame
aura trois verbes et trois à quatre
pattes rouges maman
parce que vous êtes 5,5 ou blanc ça
aurait pu
malheureusement ce que la dame qui prend
elle pas le footballeur didier le fou
c'était bien et après t'as pas de mettre
des coureurs comme comme que vous la
montrer donc d'où leur haut la main
il vous entendu parler de ma fille ne
sont plus concentrés le mafé a fait mal
du rhin c'est très très dur
c'est très très très dur
h3
ça évite pourquoi pas on s'est vite que
moi ces domaines du couloir savita h 4 h
3 des noirs un jour
puis voilà tu donnes ormes bon après il
peut jouer des coups
c'est trash 4 même dame 10,6 je suis pas
trop que ça sert et pourquoi pas
c'est pas toi éventuellement
un homme dé 6,5 ou qui peut juste
après
s'impliquent dans des sacs à même si
c'est peut-être mg3 maintenant ouais
merci ce tour 5 % lorsqu'on a doctor pas
trop ce que ça change et qu'on inclut
age 3 x 17 après moi ce que je ferais
pas été avec les noirs c'est g5 g4 ouah
ça serait pas du tout
non je ne cracherais pendant que les
pauvres s'est lancé dans un truc comme
ça
nathan savoir
on voit se doit les sa position
juste pas super mais je vous
l ai pas fun à jouer
aujourd'hui il va rejouer tempo en fait
il peut d'autre qu'on sache 4 ou je sais
pas quoi
faire un peu gaffe rires je comprends
qu'il soit pas une complexité sans nom
h4 c'est parce que tu empêches dans les
variantes d'alger 3 ouais
c'est ça ce que je vous dis donc
pourquoi pas
après 2
sélection dames g5 qui a l'air cool
d'être athée de tout d'abord qu'est un
poil mieux
j'ai du mal à m'enthousiasmer pour sa
part avoir l' envie de chercher à
comprendre les détails parce que ça joue
tellement mal
que tu dis là on est plus sur des
détails d'ordre de coûts non non non non
mais l'autre tout reprendre on prend
tous rentes ai pas tout réussi puisque
un coude dame b 4-1 coup d'objets 500 ce
qui se passe si c'est par angers 5
comment ça il jugé cinq c'est sec n'a
fait quand on l'a mis le doigt là tu as
raison il dit j'ai cinq écoutes je serai
un patient avec des pôles face c'est
juste ça donne pas envie tu as fait bien
encore plus la position mais après
contre ça marche les trucs ça marche
amado s'est affaibli les cases manche
que tu plantes tu fais j'ai 5 h 4 après
non mais pourquoi pas c'est
alors si tu attaques on va faire du
fouet f5 à présent
je pense que là bon sens finisse pas
cette partie je brosse qu'on fasse une
petite pause nous aussi avoir occupé un
peu puisque la partie est vraiment
complexe à suivre
rien c'est à tous les gars a tout de
suite
juste avant de partir il a joué quoi par
curiosité
il a joué jusqu'à tenir le coup le plus
logique à tout de suite les gars
on a manqué un deuxième coup pour la
montée
web on avait vu h4 pas de loin et il a
répondu c'est 4
il faut prendre
jordi d'amd 6
pour couvrir un peu les cases ça serait
mon
bien russe c4 en fait ouais
mais bon m'accusant ces trucs
ok donc du coup tu peux faire d'amd
s'ils sont peut-être bouffe bouffer
jusqu'à -10
et tour h5
france à damas tron
c'est le deuxième problème durant j'ai
eu trois forages il y une halte à 3 g 8
alors ouais
où se cache faut être sur damas est
cernée
de prendre ou
non à prendre 400
aujourd'hui dit que ça va
mais ça c'est dur enfin si dépôt fait
bravo
rattrapera de ces communes avant
mais ça l'a vraiment très chiant du
c4 c'est bien c'est dur pour les nerfs
prendre déjà qui est le premier avec ce
qu'on a et qui est fière d'être le bon
coup
du coup tu souffres montazeau mannix à
être pas si simple pour lui
je vais tous les coups tordus basse est
il confronté à un moment fort a trouvé
un truc comme ça qu'on a montré
alors cci te dis quoi on étudie des c4
j'évite dames 7e des jo de comprendre
davos ne sais pas si fort on a beau
s'être salaire de tuer
s'est apprécié de voir ça ce que j'ai
dit oui parce que tu m'as tu as me prend
aux 7
du coup d'un problème si ce tour bref si
ça
ça c'est drôle en dehors de problème
moi je manque story 4
hardcore un souci ou pas mais
bon ça il peut voir partout
bon alors oui je sais pas c'est pas dit
lui aussi d'une option ne pas prendre
ces quatre mais je retournerai échanger
des cinq autres petites faiblesses
tu peux aussi jouer tranquille comme 4 à
il ya des petits du petit machin
parti
tu son courant way complexe
tous à sa part du roi et fuite vraiment
vraiment mauvais lunaire à sa part de
tous enfin partout d'ici le tempo sa
part de h5 dans la foulée pas qu'on gère
une fois qu'elle voulait si ça semble
mais pourquoi pas déjà foulé si ce n'est
pas obligé puis un moment là
non à la partie comment j'aurais juré
il en rajoute dans laxe du fou basse et
surtout rage et 8 pour partir de la
diagonale en fait
un dépôt
comme avant-hier comme hier
il ne tient pas la cadence
de son recruteur
fidh
ouais je
veux te voir en votre période a expliqué
non il étonnant sera et fuite
là on n'arrive vraiment pas à le
comprendre
autant il mauvaises décisions parfois on
comprend autant là
des fois des mauvais coups explicable
c'était dur à voir ou machin
dans la suie là il est vraiment dur à
avoir
dans une prépa quelque part maintenant
on était plus dans une prépare il ya
plus d un réconfort mais là je crois
même temps une décision qu'il a prise
lui même
c'est étonnant
salon tadjoura fuite protéger cette
fin qu'ils attaquaient
est vraiment pas de raison
ce match prend d'autant plus frustrant
la deuxième place du vélo candidat alors
oui et non parce que
c'est pas dit déjà avec maxime aurait
fait une meilleure performance qu'au
dépôt
nous on se bat ça on sait pas du tout
puisque maxime il aurait lui aussi dû
changer la grinta est probablement l
heure était en grand danger c'est pas
sûr qu'il aurait bien joué on
a par exemple les numéros qu'il a joué
il était quand même très mal contre
sanikidze ecc et 24 50 il ya deux
semaines donc déjà un c'est pas dit et
de deux n'est pas il mérite largement
d'avoir grillé les candidats il était le
plus fort dans son nom l'a
nominé paul mérite enfin je ne peux pas
on va pas reprocher à être qu'un dépôt
la perdront de magnus il ya un infamant
ans après c'est plus la manière qui peut
prêter très déçu je suis pour lui le
support spectacle
les enjeux de la position masse et le
roi faiblesse qui en rouge en fait vous
pouvez fouet roi faible tu mets la même
position avec la tour 1 8 et échangent
fouilla plus problème est que nos
aspirations mais c'est pas loin d'être
égal malgré tout mais c'est pas facile
mais elle n'a pas été tuée par l'arrêt
des candidats aussi les châssis avait
pas eu la pandémie il n'y était pas il
s'est même pas qualifié maxime donc
après oui l'arrêt des candidats ça pas
été dans sa faveur mais en fait de base
il doit pas y être donc bon moment faut
aussi se
qualifiant le temps à serait toujours
d'un coup cela
favorisera la phase retour
on va prendre ça comme une malchance que
ça s'arrête ou
un an de 6 et payent le problème de base
il serait même pas été pas été donc
c'est pas
du roi est en fuite non il est vraiment
étonnant soirée fuite
non
je pense à cette frustration parce qu'un
dépôt donne l'impression de pas être
super impliquées ainsi impliqué il est
ce sont bien des gens fait d'être du
goût de
il était déjà candidat les gagner c'est
plus on approche du match en fait
comme ce
jeu
enfin je comprendrais pas que ça dure et
on en parlait mais c'est hallucinant
être entrer là dedans en fait si tu
arrives pas échanger toutes les tours tu
seras toujours sous pression un canard
aux études le comprendre quoi où les
dames voilà
tu doit le comprendre comprendre le
colonel est chiante bon il a fait des
français ok
peut-être bien joué ça dépend de l'issue
après s'il fait ce genre de rentrer on a
vu tout à l'heure pourquoi pas accrocher
vite ou
six arrivées de s'inventer une life dans
ce chat ne se passe rien et quelqu'un
qui dit oui mais là n'est pas au moins
il fait pas nulles et peut-être peut
gagner mais là il peut pas jouer il ya
un dépôt bien bien le comprendra
trois huit ça a l'air cool en fait même
pas me coule pour faire nul a une
nouvelle fois
faut faire belge a les cheveux c'est
parti ouais il est parti
et a fait plus en français s'est repris
les parties d'art et essai l'armée a
quand même quelque chose qui va pas
après ça il le faisait pas aux candidats
de partir avant une reprise
n'a même pas eu le temps de s'en rendre
compte
non cash en cévennes fois championne bah
ouais je sais pas il a peut-être 30% de
chances d'aller aux candidats on va
calculer
belle trop bas ou
après la 15 % de chances de les gagner
encore un pour cent de chances de leur
champion du monde tête
c'est pas rien moi j'ai zéro qu'on
entre 1 et 2 je pense
une ville rose des parties de temps mort
dans les eaux du bruyant n'avait nulle
rapide n est pas quand ils pouvaient
demander un temps mort
bien fait ouais pour me souffle et
je sais pas si j'aurai un groupe où
étaient prévus à l'avant souci justes
vont devoir donner 300 marées à prendre
quand ils veulent je sais pas marchât
médailles et des temps morts il y avait
déjà un drop en plus d'étendre sa c'est
possible mais sinon il veut vraiment des
partis les fouilles se passait rien
ça peut arriver aux échecs en fait on
joue une ouverture on se fait égaliser
vous passerez un espace rien
donc c'est pas l'apanage de ce match là
mais il y avait aussi des fois les
partis qui étaient des sommets de jeu
d'intensité
les chances d'aller rénale est champion
du monde un jour
par jean 25 30% un jour il ya des
chansons
25-30
limite je pense qu'il est favori de
l'être un jour compte avec les forces en
présence
après il y aura des gens plus jeunes qui
vont arriver csl cycle
et des fois voilà parce que
des fois tu as pas de chance côté pris
entre deux de tirs entre y
incarne ce n est peut-être un mec plus
jeunes auteurs imaginent un mishra qui
deviennent monstreux n'hésitez pas à
partager le temps d'éclore
réponse et ou même un mec comme à rognan
peut-être bon vu que la fan kasparov
mais entre temps tu avais un an granic
toppers qui ai pris un peu le flambeau
tu te dis bon bah oui vos crèmes
vieillir vent c'est bon c'est pour moi
mais tu as carlson qui arrive trop tôt
et puis c'est fini quant à des gens qui
auraient pu l'être et qui finiront
jamais été mais disons à l'heure
actuelle alireza semble être un
successeur naturel de quinssaines voir
ce qui montre après quand je sais pas ce
qu'est le prochain champion du monde
dans un an il ya à gagner pour chaque
candidat se calme pas facile qui sait
pourquoi pas mais c'est pas non plus le
plus probable
e
mais c'est déjà une possibilité les
qualifiés donc c'est une chance sur vite
on va dire et
après voilà c'est un tournoi à gérer
prendre expérience je pense y a personne
après il fallait compter avec les
agonies direct
y'a pas que j'ai quelqu'un vous en tête
certes mais mme carlson qui lui trouve
un des candidats mais avant il a fait
d'autres candidats en mode s'il ya deux
modes en fait le tour des candidats soit
un tournoi comme ça maintenant soit des
fois c'était match on ça commençait en
sait pas quoi en huitièmes de finale
quart de finale et c'est hélas déjà fait
sous ce format là c'était pas sa
première non plus
étonnant encore un des points ces quatre
ans et 4 réflexion
et doit vérifier je sais pas il envoie
b5
bi cinq
ans leur dîme pas mais je comprends
qu'ils n'aiment pas ça perd juste
s'avèrent justes instante damas trois
madame décisisons d'hommes prend 1,7 on
laisse le fond prise parce que la dame à
huit
un mot qu'elle a vraiment ok maintenant
avec b5 je peux te dire tu me dis que
les noirs en 2000 et l'eau même temps ça
me choque par en fait
bon bon ben c'est bien devant la fin de
ce championnat sur cette partie de merde
si le ridicule ou non là c'est vraiment
ridicule ont besoin d'ici là ça serait
son attitude les pertes et dit choqué
quand même comprends pas mais ok bah
tiens une idée enfin il n'y a pas d'idée
je pense qu'il a fait raté un truc mais
peut-être qui peut tenir je ne sais
comment
ça il ya de bonnes chances de perdre
cette finale après ça tu vas tenir il
donne pas l'impression de tenir grand
chose vu comme il apparaît non là c'est
catastrophique
s'il ya de fous c'est que même ça c'est
peut-être perdre un set peut-être pas
perdant
alors que tu meures des minutes il ne
s'est pas vu damas trois il a pas vu
damien traille non mais c'est ses taux
longs et comme tu dis c'est une partie
oued mille lots en 2000 et l'autre qui
fait pas une bonne partie qua non mais
là bas mais là c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi non mais ça fait mal au coeur de
voir ça la demande
explose en plein bon on va voir
s'ils se trouvent dans la tranche d'âge
suis sûr qu'il va voir et puis comment
comment ça se passera la finale à bath
il va pas se laisser mater il va jouer
lautrec l'option de moins et si on
essaie de s'accrocher au jeu tempo en
étant dégoûté est ce que tu penses qu'on
peut appeler la partie la pire partie en
championnat du monde ça peut l'être
franchement ce que la honnêtement entre
le roi fx le match enfin j'ai pas
souvent du sein je sais même pas c'est
peut-être la fin vu les connaissances
qu'on a aujourd'hui comparativement à ce
qu'il y avait à voir en quoi c'est
peut-être la pire partie d'un match
championne du monde qu'on est en train
de vivre honnêtement qui fait ses envies
ne s'était pas contents mais empli de
c'est dégueulasse
hyper solide honey pot qui lâche des
games a largement caruana 1 sans hésiter
en travail oit sans hésiter une seule
seconde le match caruana mettant donc il
n'y a pas eu que des mises en jeu car un
homme et une nulle mais on est parti de
combat
à partie et choquant parce qu'en fait
c'est il ya des gaffes en inde il ya des
décisions débile il ya un peu de tout
quoi
mais tout allait trop sur des pots en
fait c'est à dire la fed hamelin qui pas
ouf c'est vraiment navrant papa on
magnus lui fait sa partie en fait il ya
juste rien à lui reprocher mais vraiment
rien ça va et dépôts il enchaîne une
enchaîne
on savait qu'ils avaient la capacité de
turbo 3 les deux jouer très mal n'est
pas ouais mais c'est quand même
on espérait qu'ils aient travaillé
dessus oui
car on travaille dessus
on menace et c'est étonnant mais c'est
pas un beau mâle championnats du monde
on attend bon tout le monde te dis que
c'est extraordinaire ou quoi mais non ma
jument en porte à faux par rapport à ça
pour moi c'est pas un beau match de
championnat du monde ici personne la
bourse qui pourrait maintenant les
probables je pense qu'il va continuer
avec les antilles marshall et faire des
nuls oui il va gérer dans votre visite
va finir bon c'est pas mal c'est lé
trader 14 parties puis vite et finit
mieux cinq ans et pour sa
annonce à ira pas bien long
ce soir molmy stotch d'exactement touche
saura peut-être un peu beauf et son fou
et je vais bien
ok on guette là bas on regarde bien si
même manu doit être dégoûté non on my
knees il va être content à tence et
enlève la pression et tout
mais c'est étonnant
parce que la fatigue a beaucoup joué non
mais là c'est pas des heures de fatigue
c'est vraiment des erreurs de m mais je
sais pas fin seul
dans la mare en fait oui la zone euro
que donne justement est ce comme quand
t'as plus envie de jouer wesley
séné poggetti
bachand ce n'est pas si pire en fait
en fait ça serait jarre comme si
même si le psg ou le bayern
équipe comme ça je vais comme sainté
et dépôt géré c'est un top je remonte un
des cinq meilleurs joueurs mondiaux quoi
bon jouer comme ça quand tu es top 5
c'est plus grave que bon synthé basse et
terrible on joue superman mais tu vois
tu vois l'effectif tu vois les joueurs
les mieux formés au club les les recrues
qu'on a une d'epinal où quoi tu peux pas
t'attendre des foudres de guerre
j'espère toujours un peu mieux ou quoi
il a ajouté m c'est vraiment facile
c'est dès ce vendredi joue mal mais mais
en fait c'est plus grave n'est pas
ça va avoir un impact à long terme sur
les poses c'est dans sa nature de ce
chrono là mon avis avoir un impact que
tu as passé des mois à préparer machin
passé s'est durement
difficiles soient levés ouais bon
toujours possible je veux dire ok je
fais ce travail je veux revenir dans
chaque camp on sait machin ou tu t'es
croule du dimanche je serai jamais que
j'ai vu la différence et tant pis je
vais te faisait fort suis pas arrivé
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu j'ai un euro
cher mais trop fort pour moi et
e
du coup tu lâches leïla leïla il a lâché
en fait mentalement
ça comme ça des sacs par exemple un beau
jeu collectif mais ils prennent pas 5
buts par match déjà ici ils ont des
joueurs de classe et sur leur classe ils
arrivent à faire la différence
collectivement c'est pas encore abouti
mais
il domine de la tête et des épaules le
championnat heathcliff qui en ligue des
champions
alors vraiment un écho de faire nul a
écrit alors maintenant si je joue comme
ça en fait il veut un mélange raconte
plus rien il fait ce qu'il veut
mais les intérêts en fait de même pas
essayé de revenir juste de trop gros
tout ce qui peut et
immature qui me pose une question pour
moi j'ai jamais lu j'ai une foi une
personne sûre avec cette personne ne
soit pas là
mais je crois que
parce que moi une fois j'étais face et
des cours qu'on donne
internationale pour les francophones et
donc mathieu on donne leur tasse un peu
des fois c'est moi et donc une fois
c'était avec du retard enfin moi j'étais
là mais il ya personne il m'avait dit
vote attend un gros quart d'heure à 6 à
personne annulait d' annuler aide il met
pays est normalement oui tu pas toi tu
peux rien te tais pays soit un véritable
gayton dimanche tableau gayton dimanche
donc à temps le temps qu'il faut essayer
de contacter quelqu'un c'était les
contacter mais si la personne des
personnes toi tu perds un trophée
magnifique ah ben moi je serais très
content des classes comme ça où personne
ne vient mais bon pour l'instant j'en ai
fait deux il est toujours une fois y
avait une personne veut citer de noms
mais jamais personne pas de chance
ouais donc damas trouve à sagan déjà un
minimum 15 km a vu ses super concentré
il sait qu'ils jouent le titre halleguen
salariés qui donne tout va être surpris
lui-même que ça se passe comme ça ce
qu'il n'avait pas prévu que quand tu
disais d'amin al wardi quoi après cette
position mais mais maintenant il va rien
lâcher je pense qu'il va te faire une
partie parfaite mais
non mais je suis très enfin je suis pas
étonné que n'est pas perdre aujourd'hui
parce qu'on ai parlé avec fab avant la
partie on disait mon ya un risque ou
quoi mais le contenu me surprend parce
que magnus une nouvelle fois il n'a rien
fait il a été propre c'est pas ça mais
je n'arrive à il n'a pas mis en danger
enfin c'est une vraiment dépôts qui
explose tout seul ouais en fait je
m'attendais à ce que peut-on déjà
n'attendez pas eu 4 je m'attendais à ce
qu'ils fassent des caps qui aille le
chercher dans une news catalan peut-être
plus théorique avec des trucs très
tendue et ciné pause souvient mal ou
quoi c'est fini ils sont amers ce fait
nul
maintenant dit très bizarre cette partie
magnus qui paniquent nif du pot qui sont
le jdj pour le lien et en tilt venez
pour des bons de well as est-ce que tu
es d'accord que mathieu que c'est
peut-être une des pires partie de
championnat du monde si ce n'est la pire
cas depuis longtemps depuis longtemps
mais durable à comparer les époques
aussi mais genre là on va livrer dans
les 40 dernières années
mal à trouver une partie pire que celle
là en fait
c'est même plus des gaffes
quant à gary qui en a perdu une
catastrophique contre krainik
n'importe quoi ouais mais je crois que
ça c'est pire c'est vrai diaries perd
sur un you lie un sacrifice possible sur
aussi soif sa touche plus quoi
mais
c'est too much l'envoyer à celles utiles
dans cette phase est un niveau de jeu et
ça profite fou est bon le truc qui s'est
pas remis dans la partie l'afp à
réfléchir cela faire b 5e mais damas
trois ont semblent ils sont publiés mais
pau en championnat du monde il doit
jamais oublier
n'importe qui en fait
non mais moi je serais dégoûté de voir
ça les regarde et revient même pas il
est full tilt en fait
mais il a dû voir doit être énervé en
solde de
caisse et les écrans a réservé une
minute
je pense qu'il va à que la partie elle
va durer 4 5 ou
finale ou alors ils abandonnent direct
je pense à soi et au delà soit il tente
sa chance dans les finalistes ressaisi
en fin ou même se ressaisir et je vous
des coûts vite
non on est même nous a un peu abasourdis
par ce convoi
c'est à dire que l'autre des fêtes le
jour c'était pas du tout ça mais le gars
qui dit que fisher le fourrage de c'est
la plus grosse gabon déjà une
explication rationnelle à sa fiche sur
l'expliqué après et deuxièmement
ça perdez pas en fait en plus
et du coup c'était quoi son application
affiche en
position montrer que même là il faisait
maintenant
c'est un très mauvais coup franc h2 bon
mais en fait ils avaient une raison de
le faire en
raison d'une raison c'est moins pire que
ça quand même
la partie jusqu'à l'or avait été normal
non mais al dam un aussi femmes qui même
fin c'est quand même petit 6 1 mais ce
n'est pas une erreur et je comprends que
c'est de la gestion de match mais quand
même non mais non mais manu j'aurais
jamais ça c'est une affiche à angie ou
je sais pas où ça c'est pour ça qu'on
fait là en plus laide que tu as et que
les deux font
que talent fou des six avant le h50 al
dam un kit remanger le mec veut faire
nul lors que tu gaffe mais juste il a
peur donc c'est quand même pas top du
côté carte ses gardes scène je dirais et
apprête à l'époque explose donc tu as
deux joueurs qui jouent mal en même
temps personne c'est juste un petit coup
qui dans la proche mais ils chargent pas
il cherche pas je demeure coincé quand
même enfin grave c'est pas grave parce
que machin et tout mais et c'est quand
même une faute clair oui mais il cherche
pas juste il s'en fiche il sait qu'il va
perdre avec les noirs nous jusqu'à ce
qu'ils ont mais j'avance je comprends
tout ça mais je dire ça veut vraiment
dire que toi aussi mentalement tu es
quand même pas au mieux quoi parce que
tu as le mec en face quand ils tous quoi
dames 1
oui en fait on de ce domaine
c'était un élève qui fait ta main moins
de 2000 tu lui dis pourquoi tu l'osés
chacun à plus de 2000 ha dont je suis
sûr mais bon après si le mec il a il a
cette émission 8 mai que le gain facile
et de services qui fait sa dernière
ronde jeudi à barboter très bien fait
c'est toujours pareil après le contexte
vous excluez enfin le contact ce pays
reste encore six parties tu as cette
position pour la gagne en fin
mai donc c'est le mélange des deux c'est
vrai tu fais déjà ta merde qui d'autre
en fait il se met dans la partie sans
trop de raison que tu refais de la merde
de ouf elle va trop vite il n'a
peut-être pas compris qu'il avait pas
arriver à changer tour si facile car ça
fait quand même beaucoup d'erreurs
objectif réussi bouge pas d'un iota sa
table il est concentré mon épaule ont
vadrouillé particulière les fleurs
non mais bon la partie mauvaise cherche
pas mais bon ok je comprends très bien
selon magnus a fait avec damien s'est
passé pas un bon coup la proche de la
comprend il est pragmatique il l'a
toujours été et continuera à l'être
et bonbons meilleur ça rajoute de la
négatif à la partie ce que je veux dire
après le fait que je comprenne bien je
le comprends les d'ivoire ni s'ils n'ont
programme ainsi 6 nuls bah en fait c'est
fait mais pau a plus ou moins mal joué
le début et qui serait sans fin et ils
essayent de bricoler ce qui peut pas ce
qu'il peut par ok ça va peut-être leur
dire parce que sur acquis à dammaj 5 et
c'est une double attaque
ça a été sur des 5 peut pas et
comprendre au mieux donc soit il fait
des grands rogge s'est fait des trucs
bizarres et maif et h5 mais du coup tu
sais avec les blancs que les normes
basses et pas j'aime ce qu'ils font et
l'attaqué écologique comme ses quatre
ans de jeux taurins d'abord tu sais pas
même d'un f3 pour faire faut être quatre
jeunes africains noirs et faire un peu
ce qui se passe dans la partie bon tu as
des gens de manière de chercher à
prendre avantage mais magnus en fait bon
bien sûr il a affiché très longtemps
plus 40 minutes donc il a vu tout ça et
peut-être rien l'a convaincu
complètement et si beaucoup ne pas me
prendre la tête d'action est bizarre je
fais dams est ce que damien simon fait
d'armé cette j'ai changé je veux foot
les tours au milieu on va tout échange
et puis bon bah ça fera nul et puis
c'est fini voilà
by sauf que nippo sur damien iehl te
ferons une fille qui est lunaire
et puis m'arrêter la suite le trompe
l'oeil ça va être
schwyz uri 14 ou 15 ans et échanger les
noirs ils rêvent d'échanger les tours
mais ils vont parler à toutes les
échanger à cause de son soutien à 5 mg 5
sa part les atouts rage 6 il fait un
coup h un échange c4 qui va arriver
bientôt après après ce fameux 3 donc
minutes parce qu'on joue un peu pour
être un peu mieux il fait là je crois
très bien et c4 est là en fait ils
regardent alors dire que c'est pas bien
ce qu'il a fait avant mais s'étende à m
chaque double attaque le roi le pion à
vii à cet égard dame prend 1,7
qui va arriver
attaque le
champion français 4
71% gardeur je pense va tourner d'abord
cette finale
mais bon ça c'est très bien vraiment il
n'ya pas un grand perdu c'est ça qui est
fou banier toute ma vie j'ai sa gaffe
c'est pas encore
je sais pas à quel point estimé si c'est
complètement perdant aussi a des chances
de nuls mais en tout cas je le vois pas
la défendre puisqu'il nous fait plus de
la partie et l'état émotionnel et tout
ça
on s'essayer donne plus de 43
sait comment
ils jouent tous les vitrages 7,2 me
pressait tout ça il fait la finale il te
dit
normal porte à beaucoup de pions sur
cases blanches on le sait 6 mai 5 si tu
pousses c5 tu as de prendre des
sanctions passer ça va pas le faire
normalement c'est plié mais bon
j'attends de voir
sur des systèmes juste fou des
trois à votre maire de troyes au cap le
coup mais ouais faut des 3 pourquoi pas
voilà en fait quoique n'est pas au jour
un patron mais on veut se mettre une
petite page de pub allez c'est leur
femme ça fait une petite pause mais
attend le retour de n'est pas habité
gars on attend en retour donné pour
outre les amis on est de retour pour
cette partie extraordinaire
un epr n'est pas revenue oui mais les
futurs par guy môquet mais bien de se
bouffer le bras en salle dans sa salle
de repos par messi n'en faut juste
abandonner si c'est pour parvenir à ces
partis radès partie ratée
en tout cas femmes on peut être on peut
être contents de nos pronostics d'avant
match parce que tout se réalise les
prémonitions se réalise beaucoup de gens
nous ont critiqués 1 on a été très
critiquée de partout sur ce qu'on disait
sur les années ce qu'on a fait vous
pensez vraiment comprendre bombe en
finale on a compris et ça fait très mal
ça fait mal le chat en sueur faso
prémonition bladet sq
voulais une médaille non mais ce qu'on
avait raison c'est tout
complexe
aux toilettes je pense que les pollens
en train de chialer 3-2 dégoûté mais bon
on savait se fait maintenant
sérieux niveau analyse sportive vous
avez été les meilleurs les autres sont
complètement les autres sont
complètement et je vais jamais à l'ouest
moi je pense en fait qu'on a vraiment
été très bon très franchement
des fois on en a plus on s'est trompé
sur certaines compétitions c'est sûr
mais sur ce match là on s'est pas du
tout tromper principe arriver à ce que
des prédictions non là on a vraiment
tapé juste juste
car vous n'avez pas de langue de bois
comme les autres a c'est sûr qu'on dise
qu'on pense ça c'est sûr après il nous
arrive de se tromper mais là pour ce
match là
on a été très bon ça fait plaisir
un australien du sein
pas fou le niveau de jeu dans ce
championnat du monde et les parties sont
même pas belle ça c'est vrai aussi
mais bon c'est pas parce qu'on est venu
chercher dans ce match au final 1 on a
espéré ça on l'a pas eu
magnus a été sérieux n'est pas mal
conseillé reviens je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils abandonnent et juste qui propose
à magnus de faire cinq nuls pour
terminer si manu seul à manier une
maniabilité de
savoir de vouloir
barrer mentalement ça va être un très
bon montrer difficile à passer pour les
peaux comme ça sur le jeu pour nous tous
c'est violent se passera pas on va quand
même se [ __ ] de sa gueule
bien
il a fait le petit nom de la tête du
changement de tête
je pense ce soir signé jana à fond
et janna le réconforte à fond
et qui pense un peu à autre chose non
mais là il ya que ça
bon en plus le coût qui est fort c'est
fou les trois etc le biologique le fossé
qui a trait à attaquer donc aucun me
retirer un jour il va le garder en métro
sa bonne diagonale où il vise sur f7
donc
là là là le titre lui dis que ça rentre
lapierre partie des championnats du
monde d'échecs ou la pierre partie de
l'histoire des championnats du monde
d'échecs
pour l'autorisation ou non affirment
affirmé
et on demandera en commentaire si les
gens des parties plus merdique
ce qui fait sens et que ma liste a rien
eu à montrer à faire c'est ça n'a pas
été le challenger oui c'est ça mais
c'est pas de son fait en vigueur c'est
que c'est un mauvais match mais c'est
pas du fait de magnus du tout quoi
il pour faire un bon match il faut être
deux et magnus était seul
parti dont il y avait un ânon de galles
fonde qui était bien pour à vos cigares
celle que galfond l'a perdue je pense à
metz et prépare un peu
mais bon ça arrive de se rattraper
oui non et les moins d'ailleurs
la pire partie de ce fort de l'histoire
de tous sports confondus
mais ouais on fait l'addition de nez
poudré fuite c'est un truc aussi absurde
que si genre de tennis
sur premières balles qui sont en service
à la cuillère mais même pas bien servi
quoi tu fais une cloche quoi qui retombe
oui tu fais un truc
break à défendre peut dire tiens ça
s'acquiert peut-être pour surprendre je
le fais bien je cache quelques patrons
la statue bien là comme ça bon ben ok tu
vas te prendre ça te prend
retournera pas touché la balle 3 4
mètres de la balle et
basta après ça se trouve dans deux jours
ils nous font la partie du siècle ah oui
mais ça changera crax
et pour la se définit en fait
après non deux jours on pourrait voir
une belle partie puisque niveau là plus
rien à perdre on m'a dit je t'envoie un
grand miroir un truc mais il sera futé
ou ian incroyable et puis voilà
vous mettre à jouer logique
très logiquement
le faute à la cuillère
ouais mais c'est une
tâche pas si double faute puis pas
conduire enfin parce que refuse c'est
pas bon mais en fait il se faisait pas
double faute parce que c'est super pas
le point tout de suite là dessus mais
c'est que juste utile tafer ce à quoi
il ya aucune raison de le faire hein
heureusement des dec pour mvl ça ici
j'arrive pas à comprendre un niveau il a
vraiment été plus fort que les autres
sur les candidats dans les malades la
montre au contraire justement la
différence de niveau entre magnus et les
autres ainsi au delà de ça et qu'il a
vraiment fait un trou sur tout le monde
y avait que caruana mon cas rona qui a
commencé à baisser mais avec eux caruana
dingli rennes bat de ce sont ces les
deux joueurs qui faisait peur à manu
c'est ces deux jours nous en tant
qu'observateur convoyait pouvoir poser
un problème mais comme ces deux joueurs
ont régressé à cause de la pandémie ben
ça laisse un vide derrière en fait
on va encore faire une comparaison
tennistique mais c'est comme quand il
reste à djoko et puis tapez du fait des
tas plus nadal est à la vente et un peu
m lle d'algérie qui arrive c'est un peu
des clients de pierre rouge à ou quoi ou
et duda par exemple mais en fait de
cette génération là en fait si tu si tu
enlèves caruana eding
un magnus il joue sans point au dessus
en fait il n'y a pas de match
il est beaucoup trop fort
et que ce soit que ce soit mvl que ce
soit
riche ou que ce soit les bonnes que ce
soit guiry que ce soit ce serait la même
chose
après bon sait jamais un match s'il peut
se passer des choses mais normalement il
est juste trop dessus donc
ouais j'ai une petite part d'incertitude
s'est passé mais qu'un pas en forme que
si que ça non john 2013 que c'est
toujours un peu pareil
il domine magnus il domine sa génération
de la tête et des épaules et il mérite
complètement cette victoire qui est en
train de se dessiner en dans ce match
après
les quarts yakine
non car il est moins fort tandis que la
réforme mais il a donné du fil à retorde
dans le match ça c'est sûr
what if you jack pour le détrôner que 10
à chelsea
battu magnus en demi finale de coupe du
monde et qui peut aussi pas de faire
quelque chose mais c'est sûr que ce
seront des joueurs d'une autre
génération année cipango des gens comme
ça ça peut être très bien
ça peut très bien être ce trafic ou un
tout à fin
mai sur cette génération là sur sa
génération magnus il les a juste écrasé
en fait
atteint titan colossal
fasse
des petits titan a des petits titan est
colossal aide
c'est vrai qu'un titan colossal ça fait
mal hein quand même je sais pas le plus
fort des titres comme si ce déplacement
très dur à maîtriser le colossal il est
très lourd
l'assaillant quoi
mais je pense quoi l'assaillant s'est en
fait des titans
bassin m'améliorer visuellement il n'a
pas l'air si fort non mais bon déjà il
s'est lié à toujours su un il a toujours
su que ça déjà c'est une grande
puissance toujours ça puis la saillie
quoi tout le temps ils sont fous
l'objectif
mais j'ai envie de te dire le tout en
cuir à sède visuellement est vrai fort
des véhicules il a son armure naturelle
[Musique]
dans un pacte à l'épaule
c'est en charrette quoi et bien la
charrette je transporte les trucs mais
donne mâchoire
on ne te rendre compte qu'il avait un
pion de moi mais sans rail arraché par
alan époux est un peu
c'est quoi comme titan n'est possible
aucun dépôt sur titan d'euros drive
il est très bon il rampait quand
j'en aurai pu être très fort en vrai
l'euro drive s'il avait été normalement
va tenir debout ouais ouais si j'avais
été normalement c'est juste qu'il sait
pas injecter de ma faim en outre au trot
aime pas trop fort d'offres mais c'est
censé être un très gros titres on en
fait un très bon titan bah je sais pas
où ils voulaient faire quoi il m'a
expliqué sa fille non mais
essuie la plus jamais revu il est mort
en faisant des charges dans la tête pour
déjà y avait pas de 6e faisait bouffer
devenez un
nom même pas bouffer
vous terminez à base de roquettes
attention au spoil tient ses sorties à 4
ans
va lui donner pour la barre c'est pas
sympa dynamique
bas il espère via sony conneries
s'en sortir par chance un policier qui
gagne bas ses pions de plus en fait un
bond plus il ya des pièces plus active
rien de fougue et 3 comme il est beau
damas est bien placé la structure pions
sympa tu fais tourner quatre ça va pas
mal
tu défends des quatre un peu plus tu
regardes h4 de l'autre côté
tous gagnent là
1 et pose ses petites emplettes râle
c'est le saumon colossal est ici qu un
saumon kaushal le titan se monal grâce à
un énorme somme où et
quand remonte la rivière wei défaut
népotisme petit à
la parade avant d'être totalement le
match aller on va si on serait pas bien
sûr ta palois de diva pause d'échec
je pense que t'as pas le droit je ne
pensera pas trop bien vu que
les sponsors tout ça aussi
c'est pas trop exagérer que de prétendre
ne connaît pas le niveau alors qu'il a
réalisé avec hun sen à partie du
championnat du monde la plus précise est
aussi la plus longue est la partie la
plus précise c'est
ça c'est faux vrai pour chaque jour à ce
truc est la plus longue bayard est
blogueur phan partie longue
ça peut être long cependant que c'est
bien car c'est comme s'il me dit mahut
isner c'était le match le plus abouti
internautes à nice
c'était le plus abouti s'adjuge 0,79 oui
bon ça c'est sûr
on au tour d'après sap a fait long feu
mais on a des courbatures de partout je
veux plus faire un service mais cette
défaite va parti soit longue c'est pas
rien d'admirable séduction quoi j'ai une
super partie une fois dont le design hot
vidéo murray
respectivement c'était une des parties
les plus aboutis le théâtre enfin j'y
fais ton pays tu
vas forcément c'est à dire abouti que
j'étais guadeloupe gagnant et je suis
très heureux de gagner autant tu es
tombé t'as pas assez de tandt avait
foncé quatre heures tu es tombé
ça c'est pas un gage de qualité après
qu'ils soient allés au bout d'eux-mêmes
que magnus et une volonté de gagner de
faire ça c'est vrai c'est des choses
différentes en fait on ne juge pas
l'intention après ça dépend aussi de
domaine les domaines où la durée et fait
aussi partie d'un gage de qualité et
c'est pas le cas aux échecs
c'est vraiment très heureux de la
connerie
heureusement oui fin à la double heureux
de rien
forcément c'est décevant
karlsson fasse une connerie avec ça
passe quand même nul pour que ce soit
vraiment la pire
on se ramasse il va pas faire
non c'est beaucoup trop facile
ouais une partie aurait pu être une
partie de sa bataille cotés moi
ouais mais bon je pense au bâton il
serait prêt de maturité mange au moins
dix est beaucoup plus sincère
je n'ai pas vu nu 3,00 un bon jeu rapide
à ce point bas mais revient
10% ne sais pas ça dépend pas d'un dépôt
en fait aux dépens de dan human
du système sur le sahara t + 6 10% t'es
gentil quand même et à trois coups quand
même un qui donnent plus ils donnent
tous genres quand même plus
oui puisque 86 ans d'ordis mais en fait
non en fait quand on dit des vendeurs
disent quand il a un coût super chelou
qui donne un truc incroyable et tous les
autres coûts c'est normal là faut voir
l'endormir et un coup très bizarre donc
quoi que tu joues tu fait très bien que
la mère 25 86 tandem 518 85 73
bon il joue le meilleur coup mais
c'est pas du tout déjà introuvable un
coup bizarre ça coûte normal tu défends
ton qui ont des cartes bien comme il
faut tu mets une pression sur h4 tu
menaces des tours f4 pour aller faire
pression sur m c'est un peu plus donc tu
chose quoi
donc
voilà déjà
et donc oui c'est assez facile pour lui
de trouver un de ces coups là qui va
être dit va faire mal quoi et en plus ce
n'est au delà de ça n'est pas il a
complètement
a pu l'ère du tout concerné par la
partie donc sam et 1 et qu'ils fassent
la défense la plus nos meilleurs jeunes
as
aussi sortant des finales dames
et a priori tu remets ta d'avancé 5 un
truc que même des sept fermes b3 a4 a5
a6
a7 10% j'ai été assez intimiste pour
naître au
bon c'est pas trop parce qu'il fait
n'est pas si il a pas l'air
il à m car mentalement
donc l'angle j'imagine qu'on me reproche
quatre passages
s'assure d'apprendre à dalby 8 échecs et
on bouffe la tournée encore un pion il
ya déjà cette menace a des formes il ya
les tours f4
ça fait beaucoup
et à lefka sur la laisse à sa report
serait beau fixe pas ce report
notre analyse va le défoncer
bac est ce que je suis
je vais demander l'air
peut-être le dernier mot sera là lui
c'est d'ailleurs
à cela la messe est dite
aujourd'hui je reviens le temps de
présence donné pour la table en fait je
crois que c'est pire que jamais
étonnant
mais pour un écho il a lâché prise là
encore le temps
la liste
sa place à commenter parce qu'après en
avoir lancé
ça c'est incroyable
c'est à dire bah déjà bon remy remet
donc les peurs
que ça aurait pu être n'importe quel
autre challenge ça a été la même sauce
au porteur on sait pas en fait chaque
fois c'est une autre histoire mais en
fait ce qui est des soit c'est pas
qu'ils perdent c'est qu'en fait il n'a
jamais semblé être dans le match il est
pas rentré en manuels à peu pris sa
chance n'a pas mis magnus en difficulté
mais trouver tristana 3,6 à jouer
meilleur d'elles quoi les le zig zag fin
à
ces dérives elle l'atv level 2 déjà
2 et gitana enfin un catastrophique en
fait
est le terreau meeting à la peau pic se
taper sur la gueule qui résiste à rien
si mes calculs sont exacts a dit plus
jamais
et calculs sont exacts
ou des fibres ne sais pas quoi dire une
merde en plus
mais face à par l'espagnol ça a déjà
commencé avant le match abbaoui 1
a été très bon dans cette élimination
quicktime web on respecte pas trop quoi
by meurt en face tu lui mets un orgueil
pas sûr car trop faire le point avec ses
calculs quoi ou nouveau calcul tokyo
je me suis tu vois finale dames comme
prévu peut-être pas échangé la tour mais
bon ya pas encore des six
bon je pense tout près aussi c'est
normal et puis on prend j'imagine tout
reproche ah non mais pas trop fâché 400
g 4 par contre
d'autant comme ça c'est maintenant
on est bien
mais bon il va jouer la finale de
sa prise
à moins qu'ils tentent un père petit
mais ça il va lancer mécaniquement b30
restaurant h2i bien caché
je mets des coins du pays
chaque
respring
way sur madame c4 et ds4
wife et
382 derick ho
hau wah
[Musique]
3,4
peut-être ces cinq ans on est un peu
obligé
je me disais c'est une belle case avec
b3d maintenant
wine atteint
6 10 essais on voit l'étendue des dégâts
à
6,68 dams et
5ème 7,57 je sais pas
7 10 à 3 5 85 m
on se faire racheter club 0,25 attention
c'est bien simple jmj 58
48 6 rebonds et pau fin c'est vraiment
insupportable
c'est après demain va pas dans le sens
où la partira quelconque intérêt sportif
mais intéressant de voir sur l'attitude
oui
il tente un baroud d'honneur perdre avec
panache bam hached
je crois que j'en tellement meurs
je sais pas
je ne sais pas trop il à la culotte
c'est que ça se termine on avis donc
pensez à faire avec 2.3 points en quatre
points d'écart le match
à deux points ça suffit mais
magnus il va essayer d'engranger les
victoires au blanc maintenant on s'en
fout et l'autre vers des partis comme ça
va mieux si tu fais des dames 1 7 et 2
fera nul et suffit pas d'aimer ça tu vas
te battre je te fais des rois il fit à
chaque ronde et votre bonne trajectoire
si tu fais tu fais des dames cette
éternelle
ça va être aussi que ça je pense
le temps rivera pas vraiment pas du tout
pendant 18 minutes c'est énorme et 12
coups faciles
et silva fihri 14 ans
banon heureusement d'air ça fait plaisir
donc peut-être y aura que 12 ou où on
nous on sait pas enfin ça dépendra
comment ça s'est fini
menace rythme ralentira pas la 14e déjà
le temps de préparer
avant noël
vacances aide
la treizième alors adieu mais pas la 14e
et encore bah ça peut aller encore plus
vite selon ce qu'il faut faire un
6/6 ici pour encore des risques mais bon
on ne sait même pas prendre des risques
aujourd'hui c'est n'importe quoi
il ya des prises de risques des foires
et ça va mais
bon ça va mais pour les manger un petit
truc il est bien quoi
bon et ans
un chèque d'aller bouffer f2
et d'un processus et chaque et après la
demande de saint accouché peu
d'atomes d'avocate là dessus
ouais
bah baup qui l'a pas lâché la faire il
va mais bon magnus pensait être très
précis je sais qu'il est très bon
accueil des ming il va très bien les
géométries et
se place très bien encore une fois après
le bon adversaire
serra en bout d'adversaires mais on va
dire que peut-être des trucs qui fait
mieux que d'autres
centres et de le finir
terrible
ça réagisse a toujours suivrait
toujours ce
une pensée pour voguer qui ne partira
pas pendant ce championnat c'est vrai
empêche ses impressions aux personnes
met tellement de pression et pendant les
matchs par sa seule présence quand on
n'arrive pas à jouer il a vraiment une
aura incroyable
passé que laura reims a joué évidemment
je pensais que l'aura aussi
au menu si la présence c'est sûr on
l'aura luciano
4 5 m eur
et biologiques
ouais
dessine comme on en voit
tandis que yann jouer à 2300 en cela
comme une insulte de la part de fabiano
à mon encontre terrible moi je pense que
je vaux mieux que ça calme non mais moi
fabien delahaye fait un commentaire
nord-mali te dis pas waouh quel parti
kwa
indigne d'un parti kurde ya du monde qui
l'a fait avec les normes
restent polis
parle-moi poliment fabiano déjà
c'est pas une petite union partir
d'un catalogue
c'est vrai que ce bug
pur masochisme
fait avec la 3g et 3g 8
marty mcfly qui doit être aux alentours
de 23 il ya un 23 sortirait de cette
partie hyper énerve et ouais oui tu
pleurais je pourrais faire une partie
comme ça au noir mais oui j'aurais
l'impression d'être acteur belge est mon
baptême à partie
clairement
il
le parti
cherche sony l'ouverture ni l'origine ni
après tes impressions un peu moins bien
neil damas trois ratés bon ben on va
voir la finale à quoi elle ressemble
mais
je serais étonné que ça ce matin il est
tout d'un coup
c'était vrai
non craquage mentale
la la la défaite on 135 où il y aura
coûté très cher au final un bon on
pensé que ce serait aussi le temps du
match oui
voir comment il réagit ben voilà qu'on
imagine
qu'il réagit pas du tout il a à mort
mais c'est vrai que
j'aurais saisi sa chance dans les
premières parties ou banyuls était pas
au top hat a échangé scénario
complètement c'est le scénario du match
mais pire tu perds et a pas de regret je
faisais ma chance c'est pas passé où
j'ai pris trop de risques et gfr
ex coup voici jusqu'au échiquier il
réagit plus en fait donc évident à vos
quatre héros g8
donc la came à leur échiquier bloqué au
coude avant ils avancent plus
aller il va perdre et avoir des regrets
regretté de pas avoir fait son match
ouais alors là tu as tous les regards du
monde
et au ksk liquide menti stockfisch bois
très bienvenu dans cette position si ce
que j'avais et noir n'ont vraiment
qu'ils perdraient peut-être il faut être
sauvé le nul mais déjà il gagnera
merci manu ce fait une impression
stockfisch le trait dessus ne fera pas
l'imprécision
qui la gagne on est loin de la gagne est
bon il savait qu'on leur dit
rester m'en fous je recompte leur dis
moi je vais pas arriver à gagner
j'imagine 2 me contre tours or c'est un
bel avantage quoi
ils sont hyper chiant voilà tour à
perpète jamais de double attaque trop
fou
si tu sais que c'est un ordi je sais que
t'as pas double attaque oui
impossible de remonter deux points
d'avance à sk le stack à deux buts de
retard dans un match de foot à la mi
temps c'est possible d'en mettre cinq en
deuxième mi temps c'est déjà arrivé mais
bon c'est cet acabit en fait tu venais 4
0 à la mi temps est atteinte dans le sac
pas le discours de courbis à la mi-temps
quoi contre une équipe qui est plus
forte que toi
b 3 1 me 88 m
dos dames 8e
d'options de plus
j'ai trouvé la dame moins de 5 et
l'envoie là
je peux me touche j'avais un marseille
montpellier françois ducrocq vis
pas trop de coups là pour les noirs
oh ben non
moi si tu peux
tu elle bat les normes et moyens de
faire d'alger trois dames 1 mehdaoui 4
défend malheureusement
donc en fait pas pas encore et puis
mamadou d'abattre le laisser coi
simplement
way prévu
on soit 6 mai 24 parties dans le match
j'en ai déjà un puck 6 et puis fisher
était pas moins bon que ce pas ce qui
inquiète que les différences
et en plus sa deuxième partie c'est pas
comme si les pères du celtic pub
là c'est que tu perdes sans être moins
fort
et que
tu es mené 5 0 et passe cinq heures le
grand roque mais c'était encore un autre
format fallait gagner cette partie et
match était arrêté chez personnage de
gagner ici
c'est un autre forme
de cinq parties et qu'il y avait un peu
partie à jouer l'aurait pas gagné non
il est pas content
ce que la corde dame soit 6,4 sur
l'année montre dans leur vie
lâchait qui est une partie entre à
l'équipe capable en km semblent ils ont
deux dames chacun ou 3 et 32 voilà un
truc très vite arrive beaucoup de dames
en fait
une partie comme ça trois dames c'est
beau chacun
y est d'amener leurs forces
comment penser j'ai une fois dans la
partie un truc bizarre
j'ai deux dames
une dame un cavalier un fou
bon j'ai gagné mais j'avais du mal à
trouver exactement l'emplacement de ces
tu n'as jamais coordonnées de dames
entre elles dans ta vie qu'en fait tu as
peuvent elles faire banquette et c'était
5 juin un sentiment bizarre je m comment
est-ce que je les lis 28
mai 3 c'est beau tracé très bon
ne me vitrage 7 seul coup on prend bien
soin de jouer prend un pion
défensive il peut faire il peut faire de
preuve en faire d'ailleurs strictement
vie rangée vite
donc il à présent d'en faire ce que tu
entends il a bouffé
et je tiens rue
s'il vous fâche ceinture a quasiment
plus jamais permettre en plus
bon ben là d'affaires d'amd trois échecs
au prochain en champions
soit un des pôles espoirs
et alors il fait dam des deux et on fait
dans le simple j'imagine
banon mais même ya des magiciens qui
prêchent quatre
interprètes bon je sais pas c'est juste
que sur un banc de sable
cela doit être content c'est pas sûr il
sera content d'avoir raison mais il sera
mécontent parce qu'ils espéraient un
autre scénario
vraiment turbo tilt un
incompréhensible
non mais là c'est ouais
c'est non parti kwa
damev de hockey
ah ben on imagine 2005 et en sélection
je pas le cas peut-être b4 et b5
dommage cinq dames des cinq
2004 les échecs du coup
je serai absent lui aussi
va être précis au
cheval s'apprécient
lagaf est du même niveau que ceux de vos
rides de fisher abbaoui pas pour moi les
pires mais bon
aujourd'hui c'est pire que tout
c'est nettement pire en fait si aucun
sens
c'est le noble but bizarre de me céder 4
m dames des
8500 fin le coup tempo après le tir et
faire 2 3 échec-avant et
bush une envie
moi je prendrais h4 pour être bien sûr
bon même dame e3 panne
d'un autre
si
85% de caf sont alors dirigés l'erreur
oui je trouve ça beaucoup
ouais
il aura pas été emballants championnat
du monde
détrompe toi
même battu le record partie la plus
longue
beaucoup de bruit pour pas grand chose
beaucoup de f non pas vraiment mais
beaucoup d'attentes pour déçu par
exemple
ah c'est vrai la précision de dépôts va
remonter vous inquiétez pas épanché les
meilleurs points avant de la perdre les
analystes vont venir vous dire que
c'était une belle gagne quand même avec
90 plus pour les deux côtés rien c'est
tellement sans plus ristic où il a
vraiment bien joué
c'est vrai en plus fier c'est que tu
trolles mais c'est vraiment ce qu'ils
font
et se remarque qu'on se prend notre
chatte nous arrive est entre des
commentaires et machin
beaucoup découvrent le championnat du
monde avec celui là c'est pas déjà le
format est vraiment pas attrayant mais
là en plus la beauté du championnat du
monde c'est justement dans un format qui
est pas du tout attrayant mais de se
dire que chicken m'en parle en ces beaux
100 rue du lot mais là en fait
honnêtement tu fais tu regardes tous
championne du monde tu dis que c'est du
rapide ça choque personne
ce
hacker qui est dommage
qu'un témoin vous de continuer mais là
je crois qu'il n'arrive pas à faire le
deuil du match parce que là on a beau
moment ils abandonnent il sait que le
match est fini
mais bon sait jamais une gaffe
je sais pas il s'embrouille guinéen
perpète ou un truc comme ça mais
tellement improbable
ok
un pion pour l'envoyer il touche la 4g
trop passage et vite il permet à tout
cas pour l'instant
ça plein de tous et sur des aides de jeu
mais le niveau des cinq dames f k 3g un
dogme c'est un rêve de monter
on savait partie des
affaires des cinq est
parfait comme ça mais bon salaire
convaincre ans après je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs manières de faire
quatorze partis on est la huitième je
n'arrive pas à comprendre les types qui
ce que tout est joué comme on disait
tout à l'heure c'est comme ça à 4 0 à la
mi temps d'un match de foot peut-être y
avoir cinq buts c'est possible mais en
gros c'est très improbable et quand tu
es dans la tête de dépôt comme candidat
dans la tête d'un joueur qui rentre à la
mi temps menée 4-0 tu dis pas que tu vas
gagner le match quoi note un peu
à peu la tête dans le sac
ces 4
ok
aussi 1,4 mais c'est tout
ouais c'est bien ça c'est dur et three
kings bay 4 peut-être déjà une fois au
revoir
mais y'a plus de perpète
qui comprend absolument rien aux
comparaisons et qui dit pourquoi casero
york alors qu'il ya le plus de
ses équivalents en fait
parce qu'en fait c'est pas le sport il
n'ya pas 90 minutes de jeu et y apporte
un petit cours pour marquer des buts en
fait ces deux choses différentes
noir est impossible on va dire qu'il lui
reste trois parties avec les blancs qui
en gagne deux sur trois et il n'a pas
encore réussi à mettre en danger magnus
une seule fois
et il a la tête sous l'eau en fait tu as
quand même beaucoup de choses qui font
que
c'est dur dit elle vous dit un score
large histoire donne un score large et 1
milliards 5,3 et imprécis ça rapportera
une sorte de comparaison
pourquoi tête vous souhaitez refaire
il suffit qu'il y ait une partie pour
que ce soit relancé oui toi j'ai même si
l'on gagne qu'une ça va être dur mais
il faut en gagner deux puis trois
est prévu un craquage de dépôt après une
défaite on me jetait pas le seul 1
s'est passé way aller la récupérer une
heure donc il faut bien repartir
après peut tenter la fourchette
physiquement
fourchette ouais
versa ne voit plus il n'a plus d'yeux et
à tu reviens tu vas jouer maintenant
négocier une troisième oui et non en
fait il va se contenter de faire des
yeux me signer pau fait une partie comme
aujourd'hui où il va gagner
ouais ça à faire des parties ouvertes
avec les peaux qui tente tout ça c'est
le bon scénario entre guillemets
mais c'est pas dit un juste niveau qui
en fait on voit ce truc je sais pas
prendre le tour de france une fois tu as
un favori qui a pris l'eau on se dit bon
ben maintenant qu'il a pris l'eau va
peut-être faire des échappées il aura
des bons de sortie c'est digne des
étapes pas du tout mais en fait souvent
il fait juste il ya dans le gruppetto
jusqu'à la fin du tour quoi la justice
n'a pas la forme 1
là on voit ya 99% de chances que magnus
gain du match un peu plus de 4.5 et sera
toujours un monde comme l'a dit aussi
locaux vides ouais le mot thorax à tout
moment jusqu'à ses problèmes de santé il
ya tout un tas de choses encore
mais qui donc sera pas un truc
rationnelle super
coq la
gastro foudroyant
même main chaussures que ses mots envers
les mêmes problèmes gascon foudroyant
qui tourne quoi les huîtres qui font mal
ce très beau pays 18 ce soir et
dans deux jours sur la crise
ils foudroyage quoi
c'est quand même incroyable ça
non mais
bon 17h12 je crois qu'on aurait un tel
appui oui on repart on fait une petite
pause
voilà en fait je sais pas ce qu'on
regarde quoi
mais bon on n'a rien loupé mon fait
ça fait plaisir j'avais très peur
d'avoir loupé d'action
je souffle
c'est heureusement qu'ils ont vraiment
le temps pour réfléchir faire des
parties comme ça
heureusement mon fab
sans un bus quand même il a envie de
finir le boulot proprement
séné pour
qui soutient pas remplacer les pauvres
voilà il va remonter 1,4
on sait plus quoi dire en fait face et
c'est le néant en terme de spectacle en
termes de qualité
est-ce que les échecs se relèveront
sûrement
parce qu'en même pierre que rien en
terme de spectacle
chez cora
peut-être mettre la démonter un noyau
fille dans mon pays est un des grands h1
et tu pousses de fusée qui pousse
c'est vraiment terrible
dam des trois échecs le mouv légendaire
des ticos qu'obtient
picos coped
ben c'est compliqué ce coupé
la fin échec j'en arrive et je n'ai rien
faire la partie c'était si
catastrophique que ça à un niveau de jeu
des deux côtés annoncé que d'un côté un
revenu souvent bien sûr maïs à aller web
à new soul est juste faire drôle en fait
est une épaule s'inventer une life
g6
braves ont drainé paul a
reçu comme il veut et quand il veut en
fait ouais
sa clique au hasard
accor ouais
ben ouais
y compris aux perceptions et va le faire
petit à petit je pense qu'elle peut
faire des cinq où il commence par d'âme
des uns histoire de bien tout sécurisé
situé sera plus que dame eu trois échecs
tu me tondre en h1 et après tout est
défendue état d'âme des uns défend
défendent b&d peut avancer à fond du
coup les noirs pour des fins de remettre
la dame devant et pas un trader avait
raccroché en leur
donc oui non c'est pas trop trop
compliqué quoi
il veut juste être bien sûr est resté
coi
maire d'ignaux louis fin la belle fille
camille des quatre échecs
way-points gagnante
mais pour réfléchir à quel vent de
l'espagne je vais jouer demain et c'est
ça
qui a intérêt d'aller voir
la marshall pour voir un peu la prépa
demaini sur mars pour savoir apprendre
encore quelque chose
la bonne nouvelle ce qu'on remet ça
l'année prochaine je crois qu'ils
veulent jouer
le prochain match début 2000 23 noms
je sais pas moi en fait je serais pas
leurs notes
ouais c'est pas annoncé de toute façon
comme les candidats comme tous
les dates de rien je te les grands prix
qui ont dénoncé hier
c'est beau ça
fait six mois qu'ils annonçaient la
général mangou deux mois al avance ah
oui mais notre mois de juin au soir un
travail bien sûr
magnus continue à réfléchir
mais ces cadences et plus précis de m 3
heure sur une position comme ça
en fait je suis sûr qu'il réussit en
rapide voire même en bis à la gagner
sans laisser aucune chance à son
adversaire vous avez bien sûr
ares à sa mine le moral
c'est quand du coup les grands prix
c'est début février fin février début
mars
wim autant de temps à jouer puisqu'il va
être vraiment sûr
de ce qui va fermer ils seraient
capables de le faire avec avec trois
minutes à la pendue sans aucun problème
jusque là il a le temps il utilise c'est
tout mais
mais il en a pas spécialement besoin
[Musique]
veux juste être bien sûr
il pourrait revenir sur les précédentes
éditions et championnats du monde sur
l'histoire des ouvertures sur les
secondes balles et appelé à moins de
meubler autrement qu'en disant c'est
terrible mais on a déjà parlé de tout ça
en fait t'as qu'à écouter thymus vambre
un t'écouter puis justement est pas
content qu'on revienne pas sur
l'histoire des championnats du monde
revienne pas sur l'histoire les seconds
en les ouvertures facilement déjà tout
dit on va pas répéter mille fois et 40
fois par jour les mêmes choses en fait
vous demander là pour regarder le match
changeait du monde pas pour te parler de
l'histoire des matches de championnat du
monde
alors on attend
regarde une compétition quand tu
regardes une finale de coupe du monde tu
es pas là pour rien la finale de coupe
du monde de 1914 qu'enfin j'en sais rien
moi
non et si les gars sont là pas sale ici
sont la passe à 10 soit entre passe par
un autre match en fait
non mais je vous prends pas en fait
juste on regarde ma championnat du monde
il se passe absolument rien la partie
est mauvaise ce qui sûr qu'on y fasse en
fait comme tu regarde un match de foot
et les gars sont des passes en défense
fin non mais je rêve ils étaient arrivés
dans un match dont plusieurs intérêts
roland il avait regardé ça il parlait de
tout et de rien d'ailleurs un bon bah là
sauf que ça va durer 10 minutes c'est
déjà plus quoi faire bon là ça dure
quatre heures fin mais tu peux rien
faire en fait je regarde le truc bon ben
c'est hyper simple de gagner il va y
arriver c'est sûr il prend du temps
parce que il là et qui veut être bien
sûr mais
agir je suis à être dégoûtée de rater
son bus l'attendrait
malheureusement
c'est comme ça on a parlé plein de
choses à discuter de plein de positions
d ouverture des choix de donné peu dans
le match ce qu'il aurait peut-être dû
faire de ce qui s'est passé fin au bout
d'un moment juste il ya plus de sujets
coiffer les émissions avant l'airé cap
les machins au bout d'un moment juste y
a plus de sujet fait c'est
on peut pas être un terrain exactement
sont pas assis à la table
on a fait le tour de tous là
on a vraiment parlé de tout âge et on
attend en fait on sait pas ce qu'on
regarde
un
attend que le pion avancé
que né pour reviennent qui jouent un
couple bonus trop bien sûr qu'il avance
son pion
koné pour reviennent de la salle mais
juste poussé son pion des puits puis
voilà en fait on des scissions et adam
ont des 4 avancé le pion en baisse 6 1
bah je sais pas où il veut un peu
auraient pu faire en prenant à chaque
fois même pas ne dit même pas d'erreur
faisable en fait tous viennent
beaucoup des 100 gagne sur siph ainsi
fait un coup idiot il n'y aurait plus
[Musique]
georges s'est dit maintenant 34
vous précisément tu vas pouvoir gagner
ce rachat est parti assez vite la voirie
ça assez rapidement
ag sinko
j'ai quoi trop bon il prend sa chance
pour réception à perpète et faire leurs
adverses
a pas trop marché
ça peut faire nul en fait une mauvaise
nouvelle avec les morts c'est que g4g
proches 3
comprend adama chic
roi g dames g4 si tu viens mafia la
f3c tu m'en acheter prend h 4 enfin on
va flasher
en fait vu que même ton contre je me
passe pas
pour ça c'est juste fini c'est un
exemple
je sais
mais ça vient du thon de chance pratique
il pousse un pion cre
ont des cinq force à vendre en fait
on rit cas des six à huit coups du
recteur
après quatre
échecs et chefs de renom
il a espéré la avoir quelque chose ouais
et
de pâtes un truc comme il ya une partie
fischer cherchez plus qui court à sa ou
lors d'un mach 6 roger 14,5
[Musique]
mais bon faut pas la prendre c'est un
truc qui peut espérer c'est un truc
comme ça
mais bon c'était bien tenté de dépôt
c'est pour ça que j'aurais pris le pion
h cap breton turquie ait pas de blague
mais beau
son meilleur coup de la partie pour
l'instant ouais
un peu tard
après si magnus rate ce sera vraiment de
loin la pire partie de l'histoire du
championnat du monde donc ça peut être
marrant
vrai
nom ne jouera jamais manié sera très
complexe et les échecs comme jeu même là
il ya encore une ressource
jeu très ressources foule
bon il va trouver ce que c'est pas très
dur mais
ça qui réfléchit quoi
ce serait beau tir a quand même
ça laisserait n'ai pas envie dans le
match
et le vin gay et le vin y est
exactement et donc et donc on verra ce
qui se passera par jour de repos mais là
bon
normalement
quand le 6 minutes ça
elle ça c'est
pas sur un
jeu de plus elle mis à pied j'y ai mis à
pied a raconté mis à pied tu as dirai
bientôt arriver là il entraîne plus
l'équipe
est arrivée quand il ya deux ans
octobre
terminal au dos depuis end
alors que jenson vox populis vox bas qui
passe est
magnifique et cela
sans perdre 5-0 à domicile
benson parcours
et mode de para tous là
réfléchis magnus
racing lors il est parti
le protoss
complètement inexplicable ce qui s'est
passé dans la tête
donné pour
tâche de plomb
elle a pris
bien gagner ici ouais ouais je crois
roland de wolfe tron
pour ça que c'est aussi facile à gagner
c'est qu'en fait il ya que des bons
coups
quasiment
un f3 jouer
et ça l'abandon
dépôts qui accepte sa défaite choc en
fait si la chute ça j'aurais pu jouer
encore enfin madame eu un rouage de tu
peux encore me dis que moi j'ai du coup
à la pression final de la partie
tout cela dit ce n'est pas avec 94 km
veulent partir et en fait c'est
tellement généreux leur précision mais
je me demande si c'est pas fait exprès
pour que les gens aient l'impression
très bien jouer un
sketch voilà partie intégrante des
gets mais on sait pas pourquoi il avait
jusque là en vrai il ya eu même pas eu
un piège
non mais c'est parce que il l'accepté
pas enfin je sais pas
bon là
c'était plus quoi dire non mais juste
fait quatre arcs la cause est entendue
quoi donc mais ouais c'était pas une
bonne partie
carlson voilà la cause est entendue et
voilà on se retrouve dans deux jours
après demain à eux demain il y aura un
petit nostradamus qui partira il m'a pas
répondu l'admp à 18 19 heures quelque
chose comme ça je vais pas faire trop
tard at on pu mettre un petit tweet pour
prévenir tout le monde est donc
[Musique]
ouais on verra la fin s'il n'est pas
autant de quelque chose aussi fait juste
des nuls vite histoire de passer la fin
du match dur à dire ce qui va nous faire
mais voilà aujourd'hui c'était très
spécial on va vous faire le petit résumé
sur youtube quoi qu'il en soit et
je souhaite une bonne soirée bonne
soirée à tous merci encore ciao ciao ban
bon dimanche et dont le résumé sera dans
une grosse demi-heure une petite heure
voix off au plus vite au plus vite merci
à tous encore là
oui mon fabuleux petit plus pour ce qui
va le regarder un peu plus on envoie une
petite demeureront du stream ah ben
voilà la petite pub à skis et parti les
a ravis de remettre les pièces en un
mois la saluant des trésors tout de
suite il tourne les fauteuils on est
bien le bon drapeau du bon côté
pour du des biens et induspal est pile
ça c'est bien ça il a bien eu le bon
geste pas de gaspiller les piles on va
tous les spectateurs inquiéter la salle
était comble fab eyes exulte safou belle
partie devant ce public en fleur en feu
ça qu'il ya vraiment du monde 1
poursuivre aujourd'hui